go live
[Music]
all right i i think we're finally are we
live
i think we are now live you have to tell
us if we're live guys
it said we were live and it said we
weren't live so we need your advice
we need to make sure we're live tell us
tonight at the real rejects headquarters
comment
alive that we're live
all right i don't know it says there's
like 43 people here but
we are live chill level how's it going
oh my god we're live oh thank god
that's all we care about all right i
robot good night guys that's all we need
to know we just wanted to make sure this
was working
thanks for being here for the test today
scott brown how's it going
tm maria hammond robert becerra chill
level
crib russian word what's up priscilla
laura m hori just keep naming everyone
keep naming it dude biff tannen's here
from the future
and also um if you're here now would
appreciate it if you'd hit that like
button
would mean the world that's all we care
about the entire world
as youtubers all i ever think about are
comments and like buttons
mark leach what's up glad you made it
also shouts out to
to ryan beatty inside the patreon
because uh he's doing a great job
shepherding people
towards these things all right guys well
today's theme
is going to be as we interact with
everyone here and uh yeah so we already
got a couple
got a couple submissions um we already
got a couple of what the [ __ ] are they
called
superstretches yeah already got a super
chat
a couple of super chats thank you both
we will go to them in just a bit
and also bobby we love you too and also
if
uh you're interested uh you could also
go to stream
labs where they're much kinder to us
over there but
super chat smart convenient for you
thank you guys either way looking at the
chat right now
all is appreciated and if you want that
streamlabs link it's in the description
box
so um all right so i thought for today's
theme because if we just did over
like i like this theme because we're
going to be covering
both um overrated and underrated both
negative and positive it's an episode
override we got to do them both
we have to do them both okay because
when we say
overrated i want you to know that these
are all
objective these are facts these are
facts
none of this is subjective this is all
proven by science
that everything we're gonna tell you is
overrated
is a hundred percent yes
oh thank you maria you appreciate the
quirky merc love
by the way oh of course yeah john killed
it this week on the movie trivia
showdown
you killed it like two weeks ago oh john
are we gonna jerk each other off on this
jerk off together and then we can
you're here jerking each other off on
the livestream come
jerk with us you can jerk us off
thanks horror and gamer oh all right
well let's go into the topic now
okay all right um i have an uh a movie
that i find to be
severely overrated which is a movie i
cannot
get on board with i i don't i i
you know what [ __ ] it i'm just gonna say
it blair witch project
cannot stand that movie okay i've tried
watching i've watched it one
i think the first time i saw it was with
you yes i tried watching again because
i'm like
maybe there's something i missed and uh
i just [ __ ] hate that movie i really
can't stand it
it's i get a headache anytime i watch it
um
you know how like people think judd
apatow is
you know people think judd apatow like
he he could use another editor in the
room because he just lets his actors
improvise and that's pretty much how
they made blair witch project
there's this giant improv and what do
most people do when they resort to
improv to try to make a scene engaging
they just yell and get mad at each other
yes and anger is funny
i just i i i don't i i think the movie
is only popular
and really well like beloved for the
marketing
leading up to the film i know some
people
really like blair witch project i
can't stand it i i think it's
very very overrated and all right
i will not you can't change my mind god
damn it
you will not change my mind and dark
side matter master i'm looking at the
chat right now
don't worry i'm gonna be mentioning that
for my underrated
john do you have do you have a pick over
or under
yeah you know what movie i think is
underrated i think
chappie is an underrated movie because
that movie got
me yeah movie got memed hard and yeah
there's some hamminess especially in the
hugh jackman plot line but you know what
there's a lot going on in that movie
that is really well executed
that has a lot on its mind and even if
it doesn't
fully nail it at the end of the day and
i there's definitely an argument for
that i think there is so much that's
actually pretty cool and imaginative and
unique about that movie plus
a terrific mocap charltoe copley perform
[ __ ] d antwoord like ninja is
surprisingly great in the movie like
i i don't think that that movie got uh
it's just desserts i think it got memed
too fast
okay you know what that's a good
underway to pick thanks dog
don't worry guys once we get to 200
consistent viewers
john and i are going to jerk each other
that's right
that's chappy feeling good today because
they're actually caught up on our
patreon to do's for the most part
um messages and comments okay so
john let's go to this super chat really
quick all right let's see
let's see what's going on over there
jump on it we got our first one of the
day for mr jean jeter tv
thank you so much he says from new york
with love
gene already super chat before we even
went live blessings
super chat yeah in the world grease and
the wheels don't even do anything
i really appreciate that man really
appreciate john campion numbers right
right there five hundred dollars in
super chats
before that's just impressive ass stuff
all right we also got a nissa we got a
double
whambow from anissa oliva what's a
niece's saying and anissa gave us these
shirts by the way
hold on let's see the world needs a
snyder cut anissa gave this one to me
and this if anybody can catch the uh the
classic
cinema uh b-movie cinema references i'll
give you a dollar
so you know what i'm gonna be wearing in
almost every upcoming dc
video that we do is this main shirt
right here
and then so anisa says underrated the
little giants
and overrate oh shiz that's right thanks
g
underrated the little giants and
overrated avatar i've seen a lot of
people named check it out
yeah in this chat the main thing that's
going on is people saying avatar is most
overrated
which has me a little bit concerned for
its upcoming sequels but okay so
underrated i love avatar
underrated the little giants what's the
little giants do you know what that is
little giants is one of those youth
sports films i've seen it but the thing
is the sand lot is the one that like
just takes that cake for me so i guess
the little giants probably
would be underrated like let's get some
more opinions but
i definitely remember it from my
childhood i don't have a great
recollection of the specifics so i'm
gonna say that that's probably an
underrated flick
okay and overrated avatar avatar yeah
you know i uh
avatar i think i told this last live
stream
i'm gonna tell it again tell all opinion
okay
so but yeah last week um i was saying
how like with avatar
i was very particular about making sure
i didn't watch any trade we were doing
trailer reactions then
now it's all about getting those trailer
reactions in here
so i i didn't watch any trailers for it
whenever there was a trailer ford about
to play in the theaters all i saw was
the one image in the opening with the
person opening their
eyes and uh t2b my favorite movie of all
time
one of my favorite movies of all time i
was like i'm a big james cameron fan
and it's been a long time since he made
a movie i saw it imax
3d the way it's been recommended how
that's the best way to enjoy it
yeah i i don't i've actually never even
rewatched avatar
i only saw that one time in the theaters
because i'm like i saw it on
the best theater
and i was like i am bored and i don't i
kind of want this movie to just be over
with
so yeah i've never even given it a
second chance and maybe that's on me
guys maybe that's on me but you know
what
yeah not a fan underrated grownups in
the chat
dude uh just shouts out to mother medusa
really quick
pontypool is a terrific movie and yes
definitely underrated great horror flick
but gene thank you so much thank you for
saying that too
and uh we got these amazing shirts from
you my dear thank you
and we got some other amazing shirts
from her fashion show
on patreon and then uh pulp is saying
yes i agree i agree wholeheartedly um
so is temple of doom ooh
that's not bad john thanks man jerk off
session
jerking off all right no bogus journey i
i have a lot of love in my heart for
like as much as it deviates from like
the historical value of the first movie
i just love how wacky and crazy it is
i love death like the imagination of the
stations and stuff and the robots i love
it
growing up bogus journey was the one
that i loved more
really yeah when i was i mean i thought
excellent adventure when i was a kid was
actually i thought that was boring
but focus journey i thought was the
better one it is crazy
and then uh and i got older i i liked
excellent adventure more
because it's the right thing to say
apparently
which is the exact exact mentality you
should be applying when you do this
topic
um yeah i would say yeah i'd meet you on
bogus journey thanks for that
pulp and hey beautiful bliss over here
thank you so much
it's going well it's going to be love
it's a good weekend better now that we
have this lovely sticker
i went to the gym today it's reopened i
wore
gloves like the what are the plastic
gloves
like neo like uh nitrile gloves or
something like protective gloves
and a mask and i wore protective gloves
underneath
my workout gloves and they're still like
half
there's like dudes there who are not
wearing masks and they're such
cocky dicks about it they kind of ruined
my day a little bit but it felt good to
go back to the gym
i feel relaxed i feel stellar i was
going to say that they like parsing you
out
they like i'm very yeah though they
check your temperature when you go in
there
they're very particular about making
sure like you're okay to come in here
yeah
i'm glad the gym is doing that because
there's a petri dish
um okay ooh nice guys good call
fractured films i love them
and then uh jimmy freckles thank you
jimmy freckles jimmy freckles
high fidelity and avatar i'm assuming
you're saying those two are overrated
i'm gonna guess you know what uh
fidelity has not gotten a great rep as
of late
and uh i'm gonna i'm gonna take credit
uh for being an early adopter of the
i don't see why everyone loves this
movie opinion on that so i'm with you
on high fidelity unfortunately because
that was a movie i watched now
and just people had said to me and i
thought myself like oh this is a movie
made for me
and uh yeah i didn't really care for it
you know what movie i think is overrated
that for some reason high fidelity made
me think of this um
to you thank you jimmy freckles for your
speech jimmy freckles um
what made me think of it i think the
breakfast club is overrated
ooh them's fighting words
and i'm like don't see why this movie is
so it's held to the
this like standard that it like it's
like this beloved
and like okay i guess maybe for the time
argument but
whenever i watch the breakfast club i'm
like nah i just i'm not that into this i
can't get into it
no in fact i like movies more that are
you know when they're like it's like
breakfast club meets this yeah
i like those movies often more than i
actually like the breakfast club yeah i
could
i feel you there this because they
probably yeah just mix it with some
other thing that was missing or that can
make up for whatever was missing for you
all right i'm gonna do a speed round
here through the comments uh to see what
people are saying
pj agrees with me on breakfast club
rizzo gaming underrated star trek 2009
that's definitely the best one of the
trilogy right there
uh overrated it follows oh i haven't
even thought about the horror
departments of what's overrated
interesting i i know a lot of people who
would throw down on this but i know a
lot of people who would also agree with
you on that for it follows
all right overrated horror movie yeah um
one that i really i really believe is
overrated
the original halloween movie okay for
some that is like everyone's a lot of
people will put that as like one of the
greatest horror movies of all time
yeah and i don't know how many times
i've seen them i've seen that movie
countless times
i've never been in love with it i'm not
even sure i've ever even really liked
oh my goodness gracious i i do
i do think that is like uh a bit of an i
feel like they've it's gotten better and
hot take i prefer the re the
the reboot that came out um over over
that with the
the zombie movie no not the [ __ ]
zombie we're not back on halloween uh
no the the danny mcbride one okay okay
the hollywood the one who
really did like plum house halloween
co-wrote the script and for some reason
everyone refers to that as the danny
mcbride one like that's the one that i
uh i pref uh i prefer that one over it
yeah that's a good cause somebody
finally i was surprised because with all
the avatars uh i thought
titanic would be like much more
prevalent in here but somebody
uh put an overrated for titanic sorry
there have been so many good ones there
was a real steal as an underrated movie
with hugh jackman
i thought was pretty pretty fun i would
i would speaking of this release the
snyder cut shirt and and what's funny
about
um what's been happening with all the
you know the release of snyder cut love
that's
been prevailing for a long time but it's
really coming to the forefront now
yeah man of steel i feel is actually
been getting
uh like it's been resurfacing a lot in
terms of being this film that is
like this movie deserves more
recognition it's actually great
man of steel i think is underrated it is
now crossing over into
getting the respected fighters they
deserve it slowly getting to being
properly rated
yes it really is i'm gonna start taking
notes because there's so many great ones
but one uh somebody just name check is
trick or treat which
that movie got like totally slighted and
just i don't know there were a lot of
problems in its release that kind of
crushed
its potential i think to reach as far as
it could have but that's a really great
and like perfect
if you want a halloween time movie like
specifically for that time of year it's
it's one of the best to watch
all right yeah i also agree with you on
that it's a cold hit though man it's
doing well
i saw another one that's uh arguable
that i think would be interesting
is the godzilla 2014 which i think is
underrated but i think a lot of people
might say is overrated
be vinyl in the chat just said the movie
hidden
i gotta get like a lot of people don't
know about that horror movie
i saw that when i was a kid it's like a
sci-fi horror film really [ __ ] good
you guys should watch hidden
absolutely i think the others is pretty
underrated
in in like when you bring it up and
people know it people love it but i
don't think that movie gets as much like
classic
love as it ought to get all right let's
see here
okay man you guys are putting some great
yeah in this chat
there are like way too many this is
great so many there's so many to keep
track of here and by the way if you guys
are new make sure to hit that like
button please
wow underrated hateful eight second best
qt after pulp fiction for sojin choi
this is like reading one of those imdb
lists yeah yeah yeah
jaws is not underrated michael ware it's
a
cinema classic you know what i'm loving
about seeing this chat right now
is that so many of you guys are uh doing
a lot more underrated than overrated
that makes me happy i thought this chat
would lean a little bit more towards the
overrated side as opposed to underrated
what is so i've seen a green book in
both
though as both under and overrated in
this challenge
you know what's underrated is uh the
help and
someone said spider-man 3 and i'm here
for it it is underrate it's not
necessarily a good film but it is
underrated i will i will die on that
hill
uh uh i've only seen it the one time in
the theaters when i was a kid i think
crash is underrated
dude kill shot but you know there's a
lot of the
you know the sociological issues that
other movies have really put a light on
i think crash i really actually like
predators 2010 and
cuban yes definitely underrated also
where was that well you know i like the
wolf man remake from 2010 a lot as well
i do there's dead silence too yes so
much good [ __ ] coming
out of this chat right now that it's
like impossible dude yes i know
give any proper commentary on any of it
it's just yes i agree yes i agree yes i
agree
james wright do you mean the host as in
bong joon ho's the host or do you mean
the adaptation of the stephanie meyer
novel the host
i'm not sure because one of those is a
lot better rated than the others
austin powers and gold member yes
absolutely the wolverine there's one for
the wolverines yes
that's one of your favorites i don't
know why people like everyone got so
hung up on the finale sucking but it's
like they all forgot that the first two
thirds are pretty [ __ ] incredible in
the wolverine man
all right john let's go back here all
right it's super chat time should we
check the uh the
the the uh yeah all right we'll just
refresh that john
and we'll go down to chill level tv
underrated in my opinion let's get this
title out of here my bad
underrated in my opinion tron legacy
thoughts
under okay chill level tv i think tron
legacy
i don't know is it underrated as like
underrate i think
what there's a lot about that that
really shine a
def punk's score was like people were
downloading that album and downloading
all the tracks and i really feel like
daft punk's score
really played an influence into um
getting more of that
synth likes like there's a lot of songs
a lot a lot of tracks composed for
movies after tron but
i feel like it was tron legacy and drive
that really
some house artists in here to do our
score for us yeah
i really think that's what it is and i
think the effects of it but
i don't know i mean uh in my opinion i
wasn't a big fan of tron legacy i was
kind of bored watching it but i do think
the action scenes and the mood and the
action scenes are really
uh worthwhile and uh yeah so i would say
tron legacy is
i think it's right on the market i think
it's squarely rated yeah
like there are things that people
definitely point out and go man the
designs the music the
the aura but then you know the plotting
the characters could have been better so
yeah i think it's it's right there in
the middle
let's keep in mind my our opinions are
based purely in fact yes
all right none of this is subjective
it's all objections all objective
all science proven that we are correct
and if you disagree with us you are
wrong ooh
all right some people a lot of people
feel hate videos about youtubers who
can't take criticism
we can take criticism okay i'm just
saying that we're right
yeah yes exactly that let's see in some
world war z's in here i've seen a few
for monster house in here which is a
movie i need to see look john we need
some organization here all right if we
have the super chat up we should focus
on the superstars are we focusing we're
going to learn
hey starting we got lynnae we got our
texas girls
is here renee jones underrated the count
of monte cristo it's a great movie to
watch
and overrated is justice league too much
hype
have never seen it and never will
mike dr uh not even the snyder cut it's
gonna be like
75 percent different from the original
theatrical cut
i can't believe there hasn't been a joke
in this chat yet that's been like the
snyder code is overrated you know i know
i'm really surprised there hasn't been
at least one job the aircut is overrated
well then i appreciate your super chat
mike thank you so much
i know uh the count of monte cristo
i think that the count of monte cristo
influenced a lot of my random
screenwriter friends who never read the
actual source materials
i've never read the sort of cereal so
i'm not gonna sound like i know what the
[ __ ] i'm talking about with that
um but yeah there's a lot of my friends
who
actually were like the count of money
chris like that's that's a topic that's
a that's a movie that i've heard many
people say
is actually underrated what do you guys
do you guys in the chat thank you for
watching
throw it to the chat that's what you
gotta do in the live stream
you throw it back to the chat you keep
them engaged
to the chat let's go to the next super
chat justice league
okay as much as i want the snyder cut i
like
i do like the weeding cut all right i
mean
i don't think it's great but i i i love
it
in the sense i do love it but not in the
way of like
you guys just don't [ __ ] get it it's
actually a brilliant
i don't love it in that sense i love it
in the way of how it feels like a great
saturday morning cartoon brought to life
um so yeah i will defend the snyder cut
and the weed
i'm going to defend the hell out of both
man oh goodness chris
there's a lot of love for count of monte
cristo in here
ooh punisher war zone [ __ ] punisher war
zone is underrated yeah
i'll go on record for that all right
john let me let me hold this and
you can look at the camera anissa
underrated
monster squad overrated pulp
fiction anissa what are you doing to us
what do you
do i mean monster squad's great and uh
and yeah i mean it definitely has
i think it's rated well among horror
fans but yeah i mean that's a 80s uh
you know horror classic that could use a
little more love in the mainstream
i mean uh yeah monster squad is
underrated now granted
wolf man's got nars i've never seen
monster squad but it's
definitely underrated man fred decker
give some love to fred decker
um yeah i would say okay pulp fiction
over okay i can
i can actually understand if someone
feels pulp fiction is overrated
because that is one of the most hyped-up
movies ever of all time yeah
it really is and uh i saw when i was a
kid
and i couldn't get into it here's my
here was my criticism when i was a
little kid
there's too much dialogue that was my
exact opinion and then of course you get
to that scene where marcellus wallace
and the [ __ ]
and your little boy watching it and uh
you know what to do
mom and dad didn't prepare you for
what's gonna happen in that scene
but they're just looking at you like
it's a good movie right yeah
well that's i mean i'm i'm glad that
that was what they wanted
they just wanted to appreciate the art
of cinema yeah hey
you know that's good and you lived in
the city
now mike will be in the chat you're
saying ghostbusters is that over
under this must be over i don't know why
i bothered to question that
over if any busters oh original
overrated ghostbusters with the women
uh somebody shouted out shutter island
just now great flip great film
beautiful bliss frozen one and two leave
it all behind
kill it if you thank you beautiful bliss
for contributing to the super chat
thank you i love your name beautiful
bliss oh what a
what a what a nice positive thing to say
i think frozen is like a little i like i
respect frozen but i think it's a little
overrated especially for how ubiquitous
that friggin song became
the second movie if it was received
incredibly well i think it's overrated
i think frozen the first time i saw
frozen i actually liked it i was i
didn't love it but i liked it
and then i grew to hate it because you
know the let it go song was playing
all the [ __ ] time and then you go to
a karaoke bar
and then some girl would just start
singing that song and then the crowd
will go nuts
yeah and then parents with their kids so
yeah uh frozen was a movie i i grew to
hate but not because of the
actual movie itself yes and then before
we saw frozen two i decided i should
probably re-watch frozen one cause i
barely remember
it i barely remember this movie that
i've grown to hate
i actually really liked it a lot when i
re-watched it i was like oh i see what
all the hype's about this is a pretty
[ __ ] good movie
yeah yeah yeah yeah i think the first
one it may air
toward overrated but i don't think it's
undeserving of a high
you know love factor thanks for being in
here matthew and hollywood appreciate it
buddy
zay beast studios what a great name
thanks for the super chat bud what do
you say
i've always thought real steel was
underrated with hugh jackman
that's something that i hear a lot of
people say yeah it's a neat movie
it look i feel like it could be more
like it could hit its mark a little
harder but for what it was i think it
was a lot of fun really enjoyable really
heartfelt
yeah yeah it's underrated i will go with
you all right let's go back to the
the regular chat let's go back to the
real chat thank you guys for everyone
who's contributing to the super chat by
the way
let's see and then we'll we will get to
the
super lab stream labs we will get to the
streamlabs
underrated five hours of sleep tonight
we got what lies beneath we got
silence scorsese silence we got b movie
we got an underrated van helsing i think
you might be alone there
uh wes craven's new nightmare is
terrific underworld
i have not seen but i know a lot of
people really like
ooh cloud atlas gonzalo in the chat
saying cloud atlas is underrated silent
hill is underrated
i agree with both cloud atlas and silent
hill i think
both of those are very underrated you
haven't seen cloud atlas but i still
agree
stop trying to act like you've seen
movies
just because you happen to get away with
knowing an answer to something in the
showdown because you see the trailer
doesn't mean you've seen the movie john
death wish three
is underrated and so is the village you
know what's been getting a lot of love
speaking of part threes
um what halloween season of the witch
yes that one's been getting a lot of
love as an underrated gem
especially in the last 10 years yeah man
overlord
is pretty rad overlord i think is
criminally underrated yes
equilibrium is pretty rad too
equilibrium another one
criminally underrated criminals dread
more
people need to watch the 2012 dread
why did avengers have to come out and
the raid
that's you see anytime a big event
[ __ ] mar
like avengers movie comes out and it's
like why did it have to come out of this
year
yeah because then other people didn't
see this other great one dredd
is and i wonder why j i think the
trailers for dread
didn't do it any favors i think it was
because like the trailers did not do a
good job at showcasing that this is
actually going to be
a very unique really great film trailers
say a lot man and uh
i remember i saw a trailer for dread
thinking that this movie looks like [ __ ]
and i'm a fan of the i'm a fan of the
cheesy
crappy you know what [ __ ] it it's going
on the underrated list the judge dredd
sylvester stallone film i really like
that one that's a blast of a movie right
there
goodness upgrade definitely underneath
right for sure somebody shouted out uh
uh
gareth edwards monsters which is a
really cool like indie sci-fi horror
movie
uh somebody just name checked overlord
and upgrade yes
and what you guys are putting in the
chat when you guys put it in the chat
make sure to read
to put if you think it's underrated or
overrated make sure you're putting uh
uh one of those there please luke
kieshak says uh
rider spirit of vengeance which is not
the first time i have heard uh that it
deserves more love in this chat today
uh-huh uh is misery underrated random
high here
are you sure miserably misery is pretty
beloved and didn't win oscars and kathy
bates won the oscar for that effort
i'm pretty sure um we got pacific rim
in here which i think a little
underrated the first one yeah i would
say pacific rim part one's underrated
yeah
the term uh the terminator the first
terminator as
overrated overrated ooh interesting
i mean i could see an argument for that
i could too
i could see without terminator 2 i can't
terminator 2 makes it underrated by
default
i mean i've there's people i've met in
my life who haven't seen terminator
2 and uh and they're like yeah but i
haven't seen the first one
and and i've never had the experience of
introducing someone to terminator 1
first
to get because a lot of times it's like
you've got to show them terminator 1 and
get them determined here too right
um it's just the way it works so i've
had
i but at almost every single time i've
done that
no one has been that inclined to watch
terminator 2
because they didn't like they didn't
really care for terminator 1. so i could
actually
see if you don't if you think terminator
1 is overrated
i love that movie i love terminator 1 um
but definitely nowhere near the levels
of terminator 2. you know real quick
aside maria hammond we do not have an
official moderator in this chat if
that's something we
need no that's why john's eyes are
darting all over them that's right i'm
doing my best over here to watch
when he's before chatting with you guys
here then i'm like
i'm doing this we've got those frozen
chat we have
three screens looking down and make some
[ __ ] eyes and we have the frozen
chat on screen one we have the live chat
on screen too we have the supers and the
uh uh stream labs chats on screen three
so
once in a while you guys might see me
doing this and that's me going
john make some eye contact dude mars
attacks i just watched mars attacks and
i think that is definitely an
underrated tim burton joint that is such
a fun
and uh wild film i'm seeing we got some
uh streamlabs
what are we having the stream left all
right first one from today
june the 20th uh is from ethan holgate
and also if you guys go to streamlabs
really do appreciate it um
if you are uh planning on like
contributing at all during this stream
and uh yeah streamlabs i know you have
to click on another link it can be kind
of annoying
but yeah it's uh it's it's they don't
take as much
fees out so if you care about that i
appreciate it but also if you really
want youtube to stay healthy then by all
means super chat
uh who's the first one we got ethan holg
i don't know
john i'm gonna [ __ ] this up that's what
i do
all right who's the first one a little
lightheaded now it's ethan okay
we got an ethan whole gate hi guys
thought i'd tell you i'm freaking
loving the last of us too people
overreacted
the leaks don't ruin the game one bit in
my opinion
it's another masterpiece from naughty
dog such an incredible game sequel to
the first
i am about 15 hours into the storyline
oh [ __ ] jesus christo man that's all
that's uh that's dedication
um are you nervous to play people keep
asking like in all the comments like
what do you think a lot of us do
dude i'm trying to avoid comments and
twitter right now
because i my car i i could have
downloaded the last of us too
um and just like oh how old seems like
most people i know that's what they did
is they just downloaded it yeah
um but i want the disc so i haven't
played it yet and i don't get the d
my copy doesn't come here until tuesday
apparently
and i'm kind of happy about that because
the last of us too is one of those video
games that has been getting like
um a lot of hate already before it's
been released
and i'm not gonna you know dog anyone
who's saying that
i've been on the stance of just give it
a chance all right but you know you said
anyone who's made up their mind already
that the game [ __ ] sucks
that's jw crap you know i fine all right
that's your position
um but i'm also like i feel like i might
enjoy it more if i wait to play it
when all that's out of the way like
like sure there'll be lingering attacks
towards the last of us too
for a while but i also am in the
position of
if i wait to play it when all when the
because you know like with the way how
hype trains work nowadays when there's
like content overload all the time
like ah you know when less people are
talking about it
i'm i might be able to enjoy it more
cause i could just go in with it like
with none of none of the echoes of
everyone else's opinions in my
in my ear about it uh it's like yeah
sure if if i played it now
download it and now did a video about it
would it get more v of course i'd get
more [ __ ] views
but really i just care about enjoying
the game more so than
anything else and um yeah it's not about
math
for the last of us too it is about
enjoying the game
when already so many people have been
hating it and clouding the
enjoyment of anticipation uh because of
it but yeah i got
i got a disc coming in the mail on
tuesday so
yeah and i mean i read the leaks man but
i'm still not you know
like yeah [ __ ] the game so we'll we'll
see we'll see i get it on tuesday
i'll start playing it then knowing me
i'll beat it in two to three months
as i hear this game's a lot longer than
the first one
okay now before we move on to hitman
hudson's question there is a question
from the chat i think is very pertinent
from
tan and witches would you rather be
overrated or underrated
in bed i'd rather be underrated i would
rather be underrated
definitely i believe in um
no i almost said i i almost said oh god
oh
over promise under deliver
in bed only what am i trying to say i am
bad only you need to
get under promise over deliver that's
what i that's why i've said it on
every single date i've ever been on all
right
i'm okay in bed and then you really set
the expectations low
i'm really sorry i'm charming but i'm
terrible and yeah and then you know
then anything you do will be appreciated
oh oh uh under promise over deliver yeah
that's the goal
that's the g.o.a because you know you're
overrated you're disappointed then
all right what what a hit man houston
say over at stream all right
hitman says underrated venom
overrated overrated
green book that's why it's so fun to ask
film critics which is a better movie
ah cause venom is technically not as
well made of a film
but dude no i [ __ ] watch venom over i
would watch venomous [ __ ] everyday
and i like green books i like green
books too does it have it's got it
right here corny [ __ ] yeah absolutely
but i think it's fun
yeah it's enjoyable it's lively
it's got some nice music it's like a
good performance disney channel film
yeah yeah right when people who aren't
very used to provoking you are like not
but you know what this shit's important
yeah
that's that's pretty much how i feel
about it and we got another one from
hitman hudson following up mars needs
moms
and get on up are two very underrated
films
get on more people need to see get on up
dude chadwick boseman did not only star
in black panther
42 is gracious and you see the five
bloods
dude you know what's an underrated movie
undercover brother
go watch that [ __ ] cause it's funny as
hell i would say
overrated since we're talking about
comedy brought up overrated
not into super troopers i think that's
overrated saying i did like
super troopers is one of those movies
like craig with your sense of humor
you should love super troopers and then
i watched them like i
i barely laughed i i don't think it's
that funny a couple people have name
checked it in here but yeah
i i laughed more than you did but i
don't think it's as great as everyone
has told me it would be
lana pico lana pico is real go follow
her somewhere
right didn't she do something she was
like an instagram yeah
or something at the very least um just
here to support hope all as well
jennifer's body is one of my all-time
favorites un
and underrated at its time i agree a
hundred percent i own that movie it's a
good ass movie
dude thank you dude and karen kusama's
yes the invitation invitational fight
is the one of the most underrated movies
invitation's great ever
like you guys really should watch the
invitation don't watch the trailer i'm
[ __ ] telling you that right now yes
set you up for something entirely
different but the invitation
is like um a beautiful film we went to
see
because because kerrygosama direct
that's what i'm talking about karen
kusama
directed it's karen kusama right karen
kasama directed
um uh jennifer's body and she did the
invitation
and i watched the invitation invitation
stars logan marshall green
and then i watched uh we watched upgrade
at the premiere and i met logan marshall
green
and i ended up talking about the
invitation with him instead of
uh upgrading he's great an upgrade but
the invitation his performance in that
blooming is
terrific karen kusama is an underrated
director
oh he's just in filmmaker and and her
and her husband who's like her writing
partner too like they make great [ __ ]
together
yeah i really do i agree with you also
movies for life
chair where i could do the thing where
you wrap your legs around
like a regular chair like a regular
chair where you're gonna have to put
your legs
down not the most comfortable position
to be in right now
really quickly just just a shout out
movies are for life
one uh i will i will defend the human
centipede all right i like at least two
of those movies i know you do
un-ironically so
come at me bro all right ethan holgate's
back thank you ethan holget and thanks
lana let's go
follow her on social media let's do one
more before we get back to the youtubes
underrated movies in my opinion would be
john wool's
bullet john woo's bullet in the head
such a phenomenal movie in my opinion
who did
oh no i'm thinking a bullet to the head
yeah yeah
in the heads uh then we have james wan's
death sentence yes that's what i was
thinking when i was [ __ ] watching the
kevin bacon movie the other day yeah
okay is the last time this [ __ ]
did a horror movie
yeah yeah and that's even got like some
crime action in it too
uh in bruges great film great filmmaker
the ref is that the one with sean
williams scott or am i thinking no
that's mr woodcock
i don't know the ref runaway train oh
i'm gonna have to check some of these
out
kings uh king solomon's minds goofy fun
movie and brian de palma's blowout
blowout was pretty crazy and uh sorry
can't think of any overrated movies
that's hey underrated is better on it
always
always if you can't do both do
underrated oh my god
yeah but i think overweight is more fun
because you could piss off the world
that's
overrated yeah that's true if you're
looking for movies to
watch underrated is the better one like
overrated you could piss off so many
people man yes
yes guys tell us in the comments which
mcu film do you think is the most
overrated yes and which decent captain
marvel does not count
just put down which ones do you think
are the most
overrated films who else we got in the
chat over here we got
death wish 3 is underrated i'll go on
the board for that we got the thing with
kurt russell
is that under it was underrated when it
came out for sure you want the mouse
correct i'll take the mouse jurassic
park 3. i think jurassic world
is overrated but someone said jurassic
park 3 is underrated
so alan
[Laughter]
coco a little overrated i still love it
though says patrick
riley oberton okay let's see here okay
so
kendall's saying and game she thinks is
overrated okay that's fine
wow i just i just set up the chat to
just only list end games
hunt for the wilder people i feel like
any tyco itd movie that isn't what we do
in the shadows or thor ragnarok is
underrated
i'm gonna go on the record there
infinity war over
okay guys all right let's let's narrow
this down
all right how about instead of instead
of
naming which mcu i said which mcu film
do you think is overrated
oh everyone's going to [ __ ] say and
gamer
all right okay let's let's not include
those two
infinity warning game what other ones
do you think are overrated i would love
to hear that and then i want to see
people
argue with you in the chat and then i'm
going to just laugh here on the corner
being like
look at what i have started the only one
i think is definitively overrated is
guardians of the galaxy 2.
i don't like i think that was i think
that one's quite
overrated um let's see here maria
hammond it's great to see you in the
chat by the way
uh a lot of people disagree with me uh
about ready player one
a lot of people seem to think it's an
underrated film it's good well it kind
of underperformed at the box office john
oh all right
then for me it's raining didn't get the
greatest love from the critics
oh that's unfortunate i thought people
really liked it oh oh yes
drive how can i not mention drive as
being an underrated film
more people should have seen it don't
watch the trailer for drive
um but that movie made me fall in love
with ryan gosling i started doing a
whole bun i started binging ryan gosling
films because of
drive [ __ ] incredible film not bad at
all
um we had a lot of love for once upon a
time in america by sergio leone in the
uh
leone in the chat here
mandy in the chat thinks thor ragnarok
is seriously overrated
i know one person who will die on that
hill with you
uh let's see here kendall brinker saying
iron man one
maria why are you pissed off why are you
a little pissed off at the moment i
don't want you to be pissed off at the
moment
okay what's going on what's going on
okay we're doing our best
all right ant-man is underrated i'll go
i'll go with you i think ant-man 2 is
underrated the nice guys that was
that's why i'm one that's on my sheet
that is a terrific
list nice guys very underrated movie
you watch the [ __ ] almost got placed
beyond the pines too
so many ryan gosling movies are
underrated
so many of them are very underrated
matthew and hollywood blonde hair blue
eyed man
all right matthew and hollywood got the
perfect one overrated jurassic world
i agree underrated princess and the frog
totally agree that's a great and i'm so
sad that they stopped doing 2d after
that movie because it's a beautiful
beautifully drawn
movie okay i got i got a couple for you
guys overrated
shawshank redemption
those are the two godfather one most
overrated movies ever
shawshank and forrest gump now granted
i haven't seen either one of those
movies
they're still over but a hundred percent
overreach
i have a feeling i'm gonna walk away
watching forrest gump going overrated
and shawshank going why didn't i watch
this earlier
i have i have a strong inclination that
the day will come when i watch those two
and i'm gonna have
that exact feeling towards both of those
films maria i'm sorry
there's not much we can do to to keep
the repetition down but
but we love you why who's repeating in
the chat i don't know just i
i i'm not and how hard it is to people
please during a live stream
there's so many people to please
uh what watership down yeah it's
probably an underrated movie
or is it overrate overrated okay oh i
don't know um okay
just john let's go back the long kiss
good night let's go back here the super
chips
guys if you're just here you've been
here actually if you've been here a
little bit
make sure to hit that like button if
you've been here for more than 10
minutes i got an underrated film that i
think more people should definitely see
blind spotting 100 percent overrated
[ __ ] brilliant movie
i'm watching the help tonight are you
excited and sorry to bother you
another one sorry to bother you yeah and
um just to balance out the scales
here on the complete opposite side of
movies with people of color let's go to
the white side
the beaver with mel gibson very
underrated
his performance to say the least very
underrated
all right okay not bad took a pendulum
swing here dude zip havoc says carlito's
way underrated best gangster film by a
mile goodfellas overrated
goofy goober said in the chat real
rejects equals overrated
then retracted the message now wow
i'm going to tell you i don't think
we're even under or
overwritten yeah i don't feel like i
don't think we're
on the spectrum i don't think we're
rated yeah we're unrated
we're the loophole you get through when
you're used to go rent videos the most
overrated youtubers you can think of
oh point break is is is rated all right
here we go all right uh let's see john
yes john now let me see can you move
your bottle out of the way please
always can always won't never
lose your nerd great to see you back in
the chat buddy thank you so much for
being here thanks for the super chat
overrated pulp fiction okay we discussed
that in
underrated rogue one okay agreed
agree i agree with you 100 agree i like
that rogue one
i don't know why people [ __ ] hate
that film yeah i think it's great
because it's [ __ ] great and and and
with the way that the new trilogy ended
it's arguably my favorite of the recent
new star wars like i like the last jedi
but but for where it stands as part of
that trilogy i think like the most solid
and least conflicting one in my mind is
rogue one
rogue one i like i'm i was really
impressed with that movie and i wish
they would do more of that kind of thing
like go go take a a side story in the
same universe or something yes pewdiepie
is overrated all right
dude yeah this chat's gonna take down
pewdiepie i don't think
dunkirk can be overrated can it mr
random hire thank you so much for
contributing buddy uh he says underrated
movies without
well-known actors true all right we're
about to disprove that
let's talk about a really popular film
that does not have well-known actors in
it
blair witch give me a half hour and i'm
going to be able to come up with
a witch brush i don't like that movie
what's a
what's a popular movie that does oh
paranormal exuberated yes
paranormal activity mika and katie you
your answer to the question to
underrated movies without well-known
actors oh wait but that's not underrated
no it's it's pretty beloved as [ __ ] i
mean it's this guy
right man all right i concede you're 100
correct mr
mr random higher but thank you so much
for contributing here
uh peter pacheco thanks for taking love
your cap oh
underrated devil's [ __ ] rejects
yes i i love that it's the only rob
zombie movie i love
john loves all of them i like maybe one
i i love a lot of them i like some and
there's at least one that i was meant
about
um but peter pacheco thank you so much
underrated
sucker punch overrated no country for
old men
and a shout out happy [ __ ] birthday
happy
birthday peter pacheco i'm so sorry i
haven't yet learned the portuguese
accent i feel really bad
ah sucker punch i mean i think it's
i mean the visuals i think are [ __ ]
beautiful and you make a great
compilation out of it
no country for old men i could see the
argument for why you someone might feel
that way you know it's like
there's a lot of people uh like in the
film field who are constantly wanting to
list movies that are just like for
or like usually only film lovers will
really love a film like that
you know and there was no country for
all men i could see kind of like boring
just an average moviegoer yeah um but i
i
i think a little country for old man's a
pretty pretty pretty [ __ ] awesome
movie yeah
i i really love no country for old man i
don't i don't want to be
incendiary but from the same year uh
personally from my own
taste i i've i've often found there will
be blood to be a
tad overrated oh my god john i have not
the letter will be black i don't love
that movie i'm sorry
i wish i did bastard about it
it's it's brilliant i love the tone and
mood
what are you clicking on john judas
thunder steel uh
shouted out the frighteners peter
jackson film not talked about a lot
i agree that is an underrated film uh we
got a knee oh we got the geek out girl
with the lovely little sticker oh thank
you geek out girl for doing that i love
the stickers we love you
john loves you i love you no you don't
god loves you you don't even know her
the devil loves you all right
aneesa thank you so much geek out girl
anissa underrated
onward overrated frozen
uh yeah i think more people like
onward was i mean i felt i think we felt
differently on it
like onward for me was such a personal
film
because like i have a brother we both
lost the father
yeah we bought like we we grew closer
together because of that loss
like there's there's so much for me in
my personal life
that correlates with onward like my dad
was a
wizard you know there's so much
in that movie i only knew his bottom
half i only knew my dad's bottom half
now we're setting ourselves very weird
territory yeah
i mean have you seen that pitch me uh
yeah
so but i mean i think frozen is
considered by many to be one of the most
overrated movies ever but i i do like
frozen
yeah i i weirdly as much as i kind of
took onward as a
more mid-tier pixar for me personally i
actually kind of would say that maybe
it's a little under
underrated yeah i know it
underperformed at the box office and i
have no idea
why no idea why i would say the good
dinosaur is overrated but that's just me
good dinosaur is overrated did you say
it's overrated that it's like one of the
most panned
pixar movies maybe it's just because
what [ __ ]
bubble are you living in a bubble where
people all loved it
it
underrated movies the american sorry
jorge
clooney bone tomahawk starring curtis
russell so very cool movie 310 to yuma
starring uh rasal crowy
at least if you're looking at the remake
yeah and hannah with uh
with some society ronin sir ronan and
eric banner
i've seen i've i've seen two i've seen
uh three out of the four movies you
listed here
hannah i don't i don't know if i'd argue
i
hannah i think more people should watch
but i can't say it's underrated
considering the fact that they got a
television show made out of it
310 to yuma more people should have
given that remake a chance
i i was kind of surprised by how a lot
of people didn't give it a chance
i think that is a wonderful western
movie i'll agree and bone tomahawk
is unnerving uh that is a
hor that's a horror movie you know yeah
that's a horrible western it's one that
doesn't necessarily like start out being
the most obvious horror movie but it
definitely becomes yeah
it is intense you got i think bone ton i
mean
it's gnarly pretty it's it's it's a
gnarly blue
yeah it's it's r rated for a reason i'll
just say that
yeah it's a stark it's a stark movie
i'll put it down don't go bananas with
that one all right
and then uh all right but but thank you
so much niraj
love you buddy we got chance chance the
tipper over here overrated
forrest gump going to corroborate your
[ __ ] scum never gonna
i'm never gonna watch them [ __ ] a gump
and uh underrated
the prestige which uh i think would be
underrated in nolan's catalog
if not underrated overall it was the
greatest magic trick
i've ever seen that's what i remember
from the trailer it was the greatest
magic
the prestige is brilliant to push stage
think about the concept of the prestige
that should have been a really
stupid move it should have
been a stupid ass
it's [ __ ] cool like it's really cool
and the acting's great
yeah and um i mean i
i think it gets a little bit a little
outlandish
and convoluted with all the cr like
wow it's just twist upon twist now and
it leans on the fiction side of science
fiction yeah it stops being clever and
starts getting away with a lot of like
crazy sci-fi at a certain point yeah you
know
um but i think the prestige is great i i
really do love that film a lot and
it's like competing magicians just
sounds like a comedy
you know well yeah sounds like
understanding yeah
it's for wunderstone it's not like john
c riley will ferrell could have made
like a terrible version of that movie
you know oh
yeah and then they instead made sherlock
holmes holmes and watson
but uh anyway thank you chance i need to
watch forrest gump one day i will
i know some plot spoilers now for horse
gum diamond dog's
puppy wow do you have like a bouge puppy
like a rat terrier bougied out doggy
uh overrated jewel encrusted indiana
jones in the last crusade ooh
that's my favorite one a lot of people's
favorite
diamond doggy puppy bark
bark at you man an underrated
upgrade yes very severely underrated go
watch upgrades
ass film matthew in hollywood i want to
shout you out because
overrated tiger king uh i've missed the
rest of the comment now but uh yeah
overrated tiger king
underrated doom patrol in brooklyn
nine-nine and you watched princess and
the frog for juneteenth which happy
juneteenth if anybody observed
we should all observe trump observed he
did in the most complimentary way
probably
but but thank you diamond doggy puppy i
mean i respect the fact that you don't
agree with us
on indiana jones in the last crusade
it's the best one gonzalo olguin says
that it should have been a stupid movie
should be the theme of a future live
stream
which yes movies that should have been
stupid and somehow wound up good is a
great one
that's a great call ooh slither
underrated horror comedy i would
agree with you there pleasantville yes
what did we say
when this is on screen i'm sorry dude
like you might have set all the tech
stuff up for us okay let's let's do this
we're trying to run
let's do this next super chat
professional let's do this next super
chat with this movie i know we're both
going to respond
we have a standard here i apologize for
breaking the uniform off
i will never do so again we can never
break this
yes always and niece is back in action
underrated
jeepers creepers too i don't think a
niece knows about the director of
jeepers crypts too
i feel conflicted because i think the
first jeepers creepers just from like a
remove
all context scenario is kind of
underrated it's pretty nifty however
victor salva is also like a
a sex offender and a pedophile from what
i understand and so i
i will just say that everything that man
touches is overrated
do you think christie ellie and him hang
out oh god i shouldn't have said it that
way yes
probably definitely that's how this
works they just all get together in a
club together and they talk about
what their dastardly deeds are going to
be next
you know what what i find weird what you
know
like i've met i was i don't know what
made me i was watching some
show where there was like a gay
character in there
and it made me think about when i was
like a kid
and how adults responded to gay adults
around like gay male adults
who were around me yeah just instantly
assuming that like if a kid's around a
gay male adult
that he's going to want to touch the kid
you know what i'm talking about
a weird mentality of just like he's gay
he probably wants to touch my son
yeah or he wants to make a game
mentality that people
yeah i'm not i'm not a fan what are we
an overrated friday the 13th check the
first one
i need to check the first one may be a
little overrated yeah
there are a lot of them i would say are
underrated but uh okay my girlfriend's
still asleep right the 13th her favorite
one
yeah i think the first one's very
overrated i know i don't i think i get
very bored when i watch i respect it
but yeah it's not as thrilling as i
would have hoped but kevin bacon we're
back with kevin bacon so that's good
um but yeah thank you anisa though thank
you again my dear
agorabovic agoraphobic fanboy is next
just hear me out lol overrated
mamma mia oh my god yeah all that mamma
mia phantom just all over the place i
didn't know it's like shut the [ __ ] up
all of our comments it's like we're
trying to talk about the dceu and all
these guys
[ __ ] mama mia guys bored of his mama
mia conversation
is the best singer in the world
underrated
mama mia here we go again lily james
might be the next meryl streep you've
been watching patrick h willems haven't
you
yeah because i saw that video thanks
agora you know what this made me think
because you did a part one and part two
okay
i got a controversial take here i
think 1989's batman
while i completely completely
understand its influence and how
significant of a comic book movie that
was
i think it's slightly overrated
now i think batman returns
is very underrated i've seen at least
one or two people echo that and when i
was a kid
batman returns scared the crap out of me
penguin biting that guy's nose
freak me the [ __ ] out but when i
re-watched those movies a couple years
ago
i was like i i don't really like batman
89 as much as i did when i was younger
but batman returns
i actually kind of love okay so yeah i
would say that
like i'm gonna just swap out yours
agoraphor
agoraphobic fanboy with batman and
batman returns to the mamma mia movies
dude you know i've watched your opinion
of batman returns literally arc over the
years
and i appreciate that and it's also i
think the one batman movie i've never
fully seen
so uh one day you haven't seen batman
returns
not as a complete film so well how do
you
i don't i just don't understand it
well you know i'm next to you all day so
your knowledge just rubs off on me and
then we don't shoot too far away from
the last time i saw you
remove the super chat all right look at
the chats again and we will go back to
the stream labs
morgan state freshman says that uh james
gunn super is an underrated film which i
would agree with personally
and uh actually a couple of people have
said that robert becerra as well
um all right who else do we got jacob
mclaughlin which james bond or just all
of them are overrated
i gotta say uh jack sparrow in the chat
sco pilgrim is overrated tonight
yeah i i i enjoyed scott pilgrim versus
the world
i i watch it i'm like i don't know why
this is like the most like [ __ ]
beloved cult
get out my face right now get on my face
with that
it's underrated and i'm surprised i'm
honestly surprised
it's rated by how out of all the move
you know how people are like going after
okay with christie elliot right in the
christie elliott situation recently
with the amount of people that are mad
about that
um i was like how come no one's ever
addressed
how scott pilgrim is like as a
problematic element is
date knives chung is her name knives
chow nice chow
knives ciao how uh how come no one's
addressed the fact that he's like
he's at least romantically and
emotionally entangled with a 17 year old
girl
right now me as a viewer i i was able to
walk because i only watched it actually
very recently for the first time
and i was like yeah but i don't think he
does anything like that was my guy
mentality but then the
woman who brought up to me like it's
[ __ ] creepy and perverted
you know how old is he supposed to be
like mid-20s
yeah at least yeah doesn't matter the
second he turns 18 it's [ __ ] illegal
well i yeah it's that's a really
slippery slope to be
to be straddling and that's a good thing
for me to keep in mind the next time i
watch it yeah so stop laughing there's
so many hahas when you watch scott
pilgrim versus the world
all right realize it's wrong comedy is
meant
to be about legislation
it's not meant for jokes michael where
forever underrated rob zombies halloween
i will die on that hill with you that's
the hill i'll die on is that's an
underrated movie hello ashley hoover
ooh ooh okay all right chat phantom in
the chat
rango underrated yes i've seen a couple
people shout out in 1917 where's the
film i love and somebody just shout out
master the phantasm
overrated halloween three halloween
three just got raided
don't take it away so so so soon i also
saw friday the 13th uh jason x
oh jason x is a great guilty pleasure uh
all of james bond movies are overrated
yeah hey ashley hoover do you know her
no but she said hey real rejects so i
decided to say hey back because we don't
have the
the super chats open it's it's i'm free
to do so
okay well within my rights john you're
going to get the real rejects canceled
all right you know what's
i know it's underrated ashley who is 21
and saw girl
you're like oh let me address her so
she'll hit me up on instagram
i'll send her a dick pic you're going to
get us canceled you're going to get this
channel shut down with your
sexual ways so letting you know sorry
for being sorry
sexually liberated woman your deviant
ways are going to [ __ ] us over
jack sparrow paranorman is underrated
and jason goes to hell is in no way
overrated that's like one of the least
respected of the series
i think i think knives out is that
someone's in the chat saying knives out
un
underrated i don't think so i feel like
night i mean getting a sequel isn't it
is it yeah i i mean it didn't get as
much love like during the awards season
but i think it was
it definitely got some love i will see
we'll see how it ages but luke uh
kiyoshik music against his gemini man
is undressed yes which that's a whole
different issue
all right you ready for some hot takes
yes underrated
star wars the last jedi i think tlj is
underrated by some the last
jedi i don't even love it as much as i
did when i once saw it
when i rewatched it leading up to right
skywalker i was like i was kind of bored
halfway
but i just wanted to say that is to
upset people here's a hot take i'll go
with
ethan holgate and say while it's on a
terrific film i i do think that the uh
on
uh the uh lone ranger is a bit
underrated i don't think it deserved
anywhere near the amount of [ __ ] that
movie got
uh yeah we actually liked lone range
yeah quite a bit had fun
i had a good time all right it's
problematic but it's good john how do
you pull this bad boy up
all righty let's do it let's do it let's
do it am i doing i mean
hey nasty jacob while you're doing that
john
jacob in the chat i want to tell you
jingle all the way i think is a very
underrated comedy oh yes
classic in my mind i'm sarcastic
i really enjoy jingle all the way i i
love that movie it's one of my favorite
christmas movies dude we used to watch
jesus
eric horseman you are so generous and
and it's
holy [ __ ] it's freaking overwhelming
overrated the snooze fest
2001 is space odyssey you are not alone
in this chat
underrated mother come on yeah it's
[ __ ] environmental
yes oh my god oh i i have to agree on
the underrated there
mother thank you for such a major a
major well i'll just call it a stream
led
super chat uh thank you so much for that
eric that's very generous to you
now stop i'll tell you right now stop
i'm uncomfortable with your generosity
i feel like i'm stealing from you but
mother
um i think is i i think it was one of my
favorite movies that year it came out it
was just so
bonkers and so out there and when the
movie was done
i i said very loud in a packed house i
just went
what the [ __ ] i was i was so surprised
by like this is such a bizarre film
and and uh some people think it's like
very pretentious and i get that
i i love how far it went and i i
i mean i hate the fact that the trailer
was totally mis-marketed but the same
time the trailers did not let on at
all how weird it was actually gonna get
you know
it's it's one of those things where i'm
like the trailers uh totally made it
look like a different thing
and the trailers really didn't show how
[ __ ] banana sandwich that movie gets
you know it
is it was a wild i really liked mother i
just love for how far i went
i very much appreciate what that
experience had me doing
at the very very very very least yes oh
oh
oh judas i'm writing down yours right
now
i got to write yours down judas i'm
looking at it in the chat but who's next
on the stream last night we got
a kb like the toy company we used to
work for
thank you kb appreciate you underrated
the boondock
saints and teen spirit overrated
mad max which mad max though there's
there's at least four to choose from
i mean john it's called it's mad max and
the first one is just called mad max
yeah
so kb is probably talking about the
original mad maxim
which i agree with bored as [ __ ] when i
watch that movie
um underrated the boondocks i feel like
the moon dogs things has gotten a lot of
love
i feel like that's like a cult hit that
really rose and and
it got a sequel it's a cult hit that
yeah i think verge is on the mainstream
now so i would say that it's probably
rated i would go with it's it's rated
like it's it's yeah it's got a sequel
you know like yeah it was popular enough
as a cult film to get a sequel i think i
think it's well-rated i haven't seen
teen
spirits you know what that is no no i
don't let's google it
you know i think it's underrated this
qualifies underrated christine
i would say it's underrated in in term
yeah actually a little bit i mean maybe
less in terms of a general horror film
but in terms of john carpenter's catalog
i would say it's a bit underrated yeah
and while john's looking this up you
know what else i think is very
underrated
the movie chucky uh the remake i like
that yeah i really like that remake i
was just messaging someone today about
it and i was like you know i i like
i really like that chucky remake teen
spirit
elf oh yeah i remember this trailer yeah
max mingela i know
l fanning is like the queen of starring
an underrated [ __ ] you know
she really is yes all right that's
dang and this was directed by that guy
from
a move no he's not from a movie i just
referenced never mind
on to the next and then uh all right
all right so thank you kb really
appreciate that so scare
1999 hey guys don't hate but i gotta say
underrated captain marvel hey you know i
actually like that you're saying that
yeah i i i think it's severely
underrated from the hate that it got
and a little underrated as just like a
thoughtful you know but john there's a
woman
oh my god what the [ __ ]
muppet hands uh overrated spider-man
into the spider-verse ooh i don't know
if i could agree with you there but that
is your opinion
marvel got slated yet i really enjoyed
it spider-verse
was really really good but the best
animation ever
whoa slow down there he says
or she they i feel like i feel like
where spider-man into the spider-verse
got a little overrated for me was that
people were saying it's the best
spider-man movie
but really that's just because i
disagreed with that and i think
spider-man 2 would toby
and honestly i bet there's plenty of
people in this chat who are probably
like
greg come on spider-man 2 with toby
mcguire is very overrated because some
people still hail
that as one of the best comic book
movies ever
and i i still feel spider-man 2 is the
best comic book movie
but you know i can't slide anyone on the
hype that into the spider-verse god like
i thought would like groundbreaking
animation and great storytelling
[ __ ] weirdly i'm kind of in the mood to
watch that again right now
i'll go with you only in the sense that
yeah i think spider-verse was great and
it was a
breath of fresh air and the only thing
that rubbed me weird was just how
how quickly because i i've learned over
the years especially doing these movie
reviews over time that
the passage of time is a huge factor and
just like the weekend it came out
everyone was like
it's the best spider-man movie the best
superhero movie yes and so uh that
zealousness i think took me a back a
little bit so in that sense i'll agree
with you we want to do one more from
anissa
yeah how many more do we got on the
stream labs we got
okay let's do it five more anisa
and uh and erica and erica because erica
tuesday
is the bomb erica i got an animated
thing i want to talk to you about can i
talk to you erica
no no no only i am elected she'll only
stream lab
uh don't donate to us but she won't she
won't talk to me in person
okay so anisa says just here to say i
love y'all
hap and happy y'all enjoyed my gifts
that's right you can see us unbox them
on patreon
anissa got a summon call on a sec uh
john put up tomorrow
let's put that away all right we're
gonna kill this
kill the supers
oh yeah this braid is coming apart
so anisa got me
she got me this friend shirt as well oh
yeah give me your mic
she got me this friend shirt as well
thank you john for them
you're welcome and then check out this
super natural shirt
from the show supernatural supernatural
bro isn't that awesome dude yes
hold on let me grab mine i got my other
one too hold my mic
or hold your mic all right but yeah she
got so
she got us some like there's more than
that trust me and she even got olivia
some stuff some great gifts and so thank
you anisa
you don't need a super chat or anything
i'm telling you that right now like
i we appreciate it but you please
refrain
because you really want to be on thank
you if we put you on like a once a month
limitation it would still take many
months to catch up to your generosity
already
so bring this back please all right
bring it back and also i want to say
tucker and dave i saw this in the chat
yeah tucker and dale versus evil
except
wait did you finally watch it yes when
did you
put the put the chat oh i'm so sorry
wait i've been
talking about tucker and dale versus
evil for
years i'm sorry you should watch it and
then you
watch it and don't mention to me i'm
sorry why didn't you watch it i watched
it around the time that we went to
oh this was probably back when the last
time we went to reign of terror
this was around that time it's been
months you've got
to bring it up to me that you've seen
talking today sorry i saw it and i
really enjoyed it it's an underrated
horror comedy it's really funny and
charming you have no idea how much
how offended you are right now god i
know you have your thing where you're
like i have a hard time bringing stuff
up just [ __ ] tell me you saw it
talking in jail versus evil
i've been trying to tell you to watch
that movie for years and now and
and i and that was the biggest voice in
my mind all right when i think of tucker
and dale i think of you because you are
the one who has led the crusade of jon
needs to see this movement when alan
tudyk said
suicide cult how [ __ ] funny was that
[ __ ]
like a hilarious in fact now i want to
go back and re-watch tucker
that is such an underrated comedy it
really it really is
and for as much as people have you know
since it's been on netflix i feel like
people have discovered it but not to the
range that they should have
no man [ __ ] that's a really you guys in
the chat seeing tucker and dale versus
a really really fun movie holy [ __ ] what
a great movie
um all right bad samaritan bring it back
someone oh all right here we go here we
go we back we back erica tuesday
in the house she's saying underrated big
fish love that love love big fish the
iron giant
one of my favorite films uh meet
the robinsons that's a great disney
death to smoochie ooh you like death to
spirucci
and pleasantville which is a favorite of
mine for sure
i think pleasantville kind of misled
people it's a lot more mature than
people expected it it really is because
it's like
if you guys haven't seen pleasantville
toby mcguire reese witherspoon
is it joan allen and uh and uh chris
cooper chris cooper
and uh it's a movie where they're like
they these two
brother and sister get transported to
this black and white 1950s like
television show
and then suddenly color starts to come
to life and
it's like it's got its messages and [ __ ]
like that and bring it but
but i it's it's very uh this is a lot
more mature than people expected i think
when it came out you know because it
looked like it's a fun
comedy that's probably for the whole
family when i'm like i wouldn't go that
far
these are pretty touchy subjects in
there yeah oh yeah because it's not
about reminiscing about those days it's
about
you know the change of time and the fact
that those days were
pretty restrictive in a lot of ways yes
but they yeah so many people are saying
uh yeah people are some love for
pleasantville in here
and overrated from erica tuesday the
whole superhero genre
in general star wars and frozen
oh that's fair i would say that honestly
honestly honestly i would say that star
wars as a franchise
is overrated because the the ratio
three out of nine of them are [ __ ]
hey this and one or two tv shows
um and the superhero genre while i do
think that
it does produce you know some some
pretty interesting [ __ ] every now and
again
as a genre i personally have been
wanting to see it branch out for
a long time so i'll give i think it's uh
it it's a little overrated for me john
joker was overrated
if you remove i don't want to i don't
know why i'm being incisive right this
minute but if you remove the comic
bookness from that movie i don't think
it would succeed i just don't
i like that movie a lot yeah but but who
wouldn't fight he's ledger
all right should we go back to the super
chats or should we keep going
big fish i want to say big fish i think
is a very
rated um tim burton flick i saw in the
theaters
love it this is daffodils or dandelions
which one
flower does she like oh man that was a
schmoed out question
i get [ __ ] crushed daffodils are
daniel one of the two
you know what i love oh hold on let me
let me move this box so i'm allowed to
say this
who plays older evan mcgregor in uh
in oh it's um billy crudup
no it's albert finney it's albert finney
yeah john you would have [ __ ] us in
the end
no it's albert finney for sure um but
yeah do you know albert finney's name
come on come on that's what i'm good for
is knowing those guys um let's see
here okay underrated diamond dogs fire
in the chat is saying
reign of fire oh i caught
some tv and i was surprised because i
thought it would be dumb
and i was really into it um oh wait
where's the ch
i wrote some down here and i was
surprised christian bale was like the
star
i feel like it's gotten a lot of love
but let's face it the movie didn't do
well at the box office
edge of tomorrow was my favorite movie
the year came out
and i got a lot of crap for declaring
that edge of tomorrow
is i think is incredible absolutely
incredible
and uh one of my favorite sci-fi movies
ever
also another movie why can't i think of
the title right now
it came out around the time of the
matrix
um it was kind of like the matrix
uh what the dark city is what it's
called yeah
yeah director of express yeah um
yeah dark city is a very underrated
movie that's
i thought that was brilliant and uh yeah
you guys should go watch dark city for
sure
oh all right p albert finney uh you know
what boyhood
i like that movie a lot but i i couldn't
even
fight you on its overratedness
unfortunately i feel like tom cruise
like kiki gardner in the chat is saying
this
um i feel like tom cruise is one of
those actors that you can hate
but will completely put that to the side
i know eric horseman wouldn't do it
but there's a little there's i feel like
he's one of those actors
like there's certain certain celebrities
out there that they're starring in a
movie that if they
like they will refuse to watch it
because this person's in it right
um like for me nine times out of ten
it's going to be peter
not a fan of peter but but
nothing that he's done in his personal
life but like there's certain actors
like tom cruise where
you think that'd be the case but i think
a lot of people will go tom cruise
freaks me out
don't like him but i'll still watch his
movie you know he's one of those with
that rare exception i think
kid cuddy 24 i just wanted to shout out
birds of prey
uh underrated i agree with you
wholeheartedly 100
and it's nice to hear somebody say that
because of all the recent comic book
films i really feel like that one
just didn't get the reception it
deserved but john there's women in it
i know what gives man what were you
thinking
these women over here i saw a couple
other good ones
i think science is underrated i'll say
that i think i because i
did not get enough love yeah for sure
i've seen a lot of overrated votes for
inception and uh surprise no one's just
[ __ ] saying christopher nolan
somebody did
somebody said every christopher nolan
said everything yeah
yes yes they did i saw at least one uh
also i really love that fern gully is
underrated while avatar is over yes
um i'll say blade too i mean i'll me
i'll totally agree with that hashem
blade 2 is
very underrated film now nightshade
novels duck favor one of them
nightshade novels is doctor sleep doctor
sleep doctor sleep doctor sleep can't
say enough about dr
sleep that movie should have gotten much
more loved than it did how
now have you watched the director's cut
because that's a movie i have often sat
here going
i think the theatrical cut is a bit
overrated even though it's my favorite
of its ilk of movies from the past
couple of years but i can see how a
director's cut would make
that a really good movie also i've seen
a few people shout out elite a battle
angel
which hell yes underrated
also i see what the stupid stuff is but
i think it's [ __ ] cool
yeah also mark leach wants to know this
is another expander the question who are
your most underrated actors minor
giovanni rabisi and ben foster which are
great choices because those dudes both
got
helicops sarah snook great actress
lakeith stanfield lakeith stanfield is
terrific
he's very underrated he is he can do all
kinds of stuff yeah i think with keith
stanfield's
very very underrated actor and logan
marshall green yes
stop just calling logan marshall green
discount tom hardy
he's more than that own guy all right i
will meet you on
luke wilson is discount owen wilson but
i cannot meet you
on that logan marshall is
just discount tom hardy he's great he
was shocker one
yeah and then bokeem woodbine who he was
in devil with
which is another under rated [ __ ]
movement all right the elevator movie i
like that [ __ ] a lot
uh underrated hacksaw ridge i mean i
think it was that that goes all right
some people a lot of people have been
saying the rock is just overrated in
this chat
i don't know about that man the rock is
uh he's pretty i
he is one of those celebrities i'm like
yeah i'd vote for him if he ran for
president
one of those people i would only say the
rock is overrated
because i feel like he's at a point in
his career where he doesn't need to push
himself or try new things and that's a
bummer because you don't think he pushes
himself have you seen his body
in terms of his emotional range
what are you talking about dude he
embodied danny devito
jumanji welcome to the jungle yes and
didn't do it
crazy john and aquafina did not do a
better job at it than he did
no not at all i would say
wreck wreck somebody oh right yeah i was
thinking w-r-e-k
uh punisher war zone yes
very underrated comic book movie lexi
i love that film i do too we saw them
we just wanted to watch like a piece of
[ __ ] for fun yeah and we were like
it was a blast yeah it's a little
like bargain bin schlocky but it's it
knows what it is and when he punches
through that dude's face i was just
hooked
yeah yeah also rizzo gaming uh charlie
and the chocolate factory the johnny
depp version
while i i sense that that will certainly
be an unpopular opinion
uh i i do find it has more charms
than people give it credit for you know
what's an underrated ma
movie mob or mom mob movie
which i watch with my mom
is donny brasco
and uh yeah donnie brosco i never hear
in the conversation about like great mom
movies
but johnny depp and al pacino
incredible film and more people should
be watched if you're like getting into
the mob movie
spirit ever i highly recommend donnie
brosko
nicole buhari is underrated i'm not sure
i know who that is
also ryan s loves that miami vice movie
uh let's get some more super chips super
chips thank you everyone who's been
contributing in the super chats and the
stream labs as well especially the
stream labs and if you're here
a little bit we haven't done so already
please make sure to hit that like button
all right we got jimmy freckles in here
underrated the last
dragon wait wait i feel like i've seen
that movie let me look that up really
let me look that up i feel like i've
seen the last dragon and you know i
don't i feel like i've seen it too i
can't draw it to mind but i will say
that on
on the heels of that another slightly
underrated film would be dragon heart
with sean connery and david the euless i
totally seen the last dragon
uh not a dragon movie though a martial
arts movie
were you thinking it was i was
you know i heard the word dragon and i
thought of dragon heart but i i i know
what this movie
is it's a fun movie is it i should watch
it thank you jimmy freckles for
for saying the last dragon as an
underrated yes
underrated oh you know what else is
underrated [ __ ] grind house
because yes you're saying the last
dragon made me think of this
grind like the nods of meccas rodriguez
robert rodriguez and tarantino
join grindhouse very underrated very
underrated
um let's see here what are you doing
john
i was just letting a comment slide
so we what did we establish i didn't
talk about the others it doesn't matter
if you're talking about the other screen
without
the attention you're taking attention
justin sutton who's our next super
chatter like little if we're eating at
denny's together
on your phone frequently if you're on
your phone does that mean you're present
all right i could be finding us
something you're looking over here at
this
chat instead of over at this chat over
here you're not
you're doing it right now wreck-it ralph
you're doing it right now
justin sutton wants to know underrated
or says
uh underrated spike lead joints clockers
and kirkland
you know what i have often mused about
doing my own film curriculum or i pick a
filmmaker or genre or something and
watch a bunch of films from them or in
that vein
and spikely is definitely a filmmaker
whom i want to
you know explore do a focus dive into
their filmography so if these are
underrated i want those recommendations
so thank you
good night maria hammond good night
maria i'm sorry if you were frustrated
and also uh we got allison in the chat
who's very adamant that we
recognize that the shining is overrated
in her eyes
overrated uh overrated i mean sorry oh
naruto
i think spike lee in general is
underrated he's done a lot of films
and a lot of them are very like other
than old boy i feel like most of his
films there's
purpose there's a point to them they're
very alive at least in the ones i've
seen they
they have a liveliness that not every
movie does
all right where are we at okay anissa
back in the chat here
she's saying underrated texas
texas just underrated overrated
california one day we will go to texas
we will let you know first and then tell
everyone
we'll do a meet and greet and two other
people will show up
and we'll be like wow this is a really
unsuccessful meet and greet
how are we gonna pay for this venue that
we booked
we're not we're not that's the thing
then we go broke and shut down the
channel
yeah you know what i'll be the first
person who knows
we're going to texas and nissan i'll
meet you here texas may be underrated
and socal may be overrated but i think
that there are parts of california
especially above the southern part that
are underrated
fair enough john mid and norcal need
some love
jimmy freckles back at it what's up
jimmy freckles every time i hear the
name
jimmy i think of [ __ ] sean penn and
mystic river
is that my daughter in there um
yeah i used to do that graham
that's all i have associated with that
movie uh he hasn't seen it yet he will
get questions about it in the movie
trivia schmo down and [ __ ] win
because there are no requisites there's
no requisite that you need to
well underrated an american werewolf in
london
that's a classic what are you talking
about pretty well
that's a classic dude yeah it's rated
it's raining like people are always
talking about like especially the makeup
and that
um transformations right i think
american werewolf in london is very much
rated well maybe it doesn't get
name-checked as much in the mainstream
conversation but definitely for horror
it's the classic wow david gandy you're
already a pretty
top pledge patron of ours we're going to
get to you in a second but thank you
david
uh zachary skull schools
zachary scrotum underrated
streets of fire with william to [ __ ]
overrated mad max fury road i forgot
that movie even
exists until someone mentioned it to me
i haven't seen streets of fire overrated
um okay for mad max fury road
i kind of meet you there
i kind of do i
didn't love it like on a technical scale
i
totally get why it's so beloved but a
lot of people
and i think you would say it uh we're
very swept up in the immediate
intensity emotional experience of the
spectacle
and for me i i i kept
going to the story and i felt like
something was
missing for me now here's the caveat
i used to smoke a lot more weed when i
was
at the time when mad max fury road came
out right like i'm
i'm pretty particular especially
nowadays about like reserving when i
smoke wheat
um uh but uh i was
baked out of my mind when i saw madame
actually wrote
and i don't think i was able to keep up
with what the [ __ ] was going on on
screen
yeah yeah i was so high
that i was like this is this is kind of
a nightmare for me
like it's not a hype it's too intense
yeah yeah i'm with you so yeah
but i i mean it got so much praise that
i mean if you call it over i can respect
you on that
yeah i mean as much as i love that movie
i wouldn't really argue about it
if you think it's overrated i understand
david gandy usually lists like classical
[ __ ] in here
um so let's see what you got thank you
so much for it but thank you zachary for
your super chat and david gainley let's
see what she got
underrated underrated uh john rushford
david gandy's all right underrated
murder by decree
70's sherlock holmes film overrated
citizen kane i understand the technical
and storytelling breakthroughs but it's
tough to connect with and you also got a
friend in the chat here who i just saw
name check citizen kane as well
um citizen kane is a funny one to me
because
i i because it's uh mark leach
that's who it was uh who chimed in with
you that's
i only feel like i appreciate it now
because i already got through the part
where i'm like it's
there's like it's the best film ever
made and you know when you look at it
that way and
especially if you're a young person now
going into it i don't think it's gonna
hit that mark
but having watched it a few times i have
found it to be an
engrossing and an interesting movie but
i i couldn't argue that it's a little
overrated
um i've never been able to finish this
that's fair no i'm not gonna dog you for
that
that is one of those movies where i'm
like i'll pick this back up again later
and i've been doing that since i was a
little kid
uh yeah i've never been able to finish
citizen kane and honestly i i barely
remember anything about
the many multiple times i've tried
starting up citizen games
it's okay it's okay it's it's from
another time
justin but thank you dave again we gotta
check out that sherlock holmes
and justin sutton thank you so much dude
underrated scorsese shutter island and
after hours i believe you and i have
talked on patreon about
shutter island and yeah not many people
saw it
a weird movie to release in february no
and uh after i haven't seen after hours
have you no
we got to do a movie night john you know
what you know what i don't like about
when you're doing
the the scrolling oh i lean too much
you're leaning
so much and it's like you're you're
you're you're doing this like resistant
this is why i agreed to be on the stream
with you so i could get
a lot of notes your body language
you don't want me near you i love having
you near me we don't hang out just as
friends i'm just telling you
that when you do that i'm just like oh
my god you're like it's like when
someone has their arms
we mostly talking about something
serious or vulnerable but it's like oh
no they don't
they're not willing to receive and then
when you do when you do this
it's just like all right fine [ __ ] it i
don't want to engage with you
three tiers in a bucket [ __ ] it niraj
krishna
over ooh this is going to be a overrated
here
you're going to be conflicted by this
this is like shots fired at you
overrated la la land and the irishman
what the [ __ ] are you doing i mean
we just gave you a nice shout out
sending you love
i mean you the next i don't remember i
appreciate that
but for the super chat but jesus [ __ ]
christ man
i mean uh which one is less overrated
though let's go
think lava land if i would i i don't
think the irishman is overrated
i think i okay here's the thing la la
land up
got a release and then became this very
overhyped film became a juggernaut yeah
and then the irishman was like overly
hyped
before it came out because i think what
everyone wanted with irishman it was
another good fellows or casino and then
you
and i oh so did i i honestly thought
that's what i was getting too
not like uh like a contemplative older
man's watching
i'm like this is a lot slower than i
expected it to be three and a half hours
oh boy
like it took me a while to adjust to it
but i mean i love the irishman
fuckton and i saw la la land when i was
in switzerland at
a festival and i make it sound like a
[ __ ] attend that [ __ ] all the time
it's the one [ __ ]
festival i've ever been to all right um
hey man
but no shame i was at the zurich film
festival saw it in a really
tiny theater and only a handful of
people were there
like a small handful and a and where
there could have been a packed
auditorium
and um i was swept up by it i was blown
away by it
and it wasn't like people were hyping up
la la land when i saw it
you know it was it was i saw the movie
came out in december and i saw it in the
in the month of september and i fell in
love with that movie
well you're and that's that's you you
had the benefit of not having the hype
wave and that's really cool
that's a real thing yeah and then the
hype wave came in everyone's talking
about like
you know ryan gosling didn't invent jazz
and all that [ __ ]
yeah yeah now this movie
is arguably better if a black person was
schooling people about
what's really jazz i wasn't even
thinking about that you know i was just
like
that wasn't it yeah at the time i mean
yeah because you get suckered into
the world of the movie and it's well
made enough that it can really permeate
you with itself i love the music
and i'm sorry mandy in the chat is also
saying star is born very overrated no i
don't think so
you know what's [ __ ] overrated
bohemian [ __ ] rhapsody bohemian
rhapsody is overrated most overrated
[ __ ] movie that's
the overrated ass motion pictures
agreed on that kartik sharma has all
right to say overrated
every sequel prequel or reboot that
tries to cash in
on nostalgia of the original that is 15
to 20 years old so if it's 10 years old
is it okay
well kartik i appreciate your super chat
but might i redirect you i think the
halloween
20 2019 2018 2018
reboot was a pretty [ __ ] great and i
think the halloween 2009 reboot
is pretty [ __ ] great i mean yeah i
think it's great too what do you mean
people are flirting in the chat people
are flirting in the chat people are [ __ ]
yeah flirting in the chat
let's get something that's great if we
can don't go on paulie you're never
subscribers in the world don't use
tinder or grinder just come to our live
stream oh [ __ ] you are totally flirting
in the chat
oh yeah crazy make your love happen do
not submit dick pics in the chat
uh i will cancel it not even ascii dicks
all right no hates and equal signs and
d's whatever i mean kartik sharma yeah a
lot of time
i i think you know what else i'll agree
with you on kartik about
every sql prequel reboot that tries to
cash in on the nostalgia of the original
us 15 years old
i will agree on the concept of that is
overrated
it's it's a lot less frequent that they
actually justify doing it
i i think there's a lot of movies that
can
uh justify its existence within that
category
but i think the the the idea that so
many studios
lean in on that is overrated and i feel
like a lot of us are drawn to original
ideas and if they just marketed the
original ideas better
then maybe we'd be a lot happier you
know i feel that
i feel that gee chill level tv says
underrated
twin peaks fire walk with me thoughts
my thoughts are that i've seen the first
super chat so
twin peaks and i need to see the rest of
twin peaks so i can watch firewalk with
me although i've heard that while it's
not as good as the show uh it's still
got its charms and may be a little
underrated
haven't seen that yet i twin peaks is
when i want to catch up with asap though
because i feel like i've missed out on a
lot of david lynch in my life
i'm telling you man your body language
when you're doing this it's just not my
like your blog do you see what you're
doing this is how i'm going to scroll
down
it's about having openness all right
like let me just scroll down here i am
as open as could be
let me just scroll all right it's just
because yeah you blocked me off with
your body
sorry about that i'm not a fan of that
i'm open now i'm open
eric horseman we told you to stop slow
down
eric i feel morally
wrong with all this love you're showing
and really quick in the chat jack
reacher is very underrated the first one
never go back as one of the funniest
[ __ ] terrible moves
um but eric horseman thank you dude i
appreciate it
oh man i look like a total [ __ ]
because i've had a copy of this movie i
know you haven't i thought about this
i've never watched it but i
need to watch this this is bizarre to
having to watch this movie
but thank you for such a major super
chat dude um
this seriously is very kind to you uh
near dark is totally underrated
helmed by katherine bigelow i've had a
cop kevin bigel is an underrated
filmmaker
um attitude you're having john
yeah of course sorry my best guy my bad
i'm pandering sorry
pandering because you know everyone
loves
catherine bigelow that [ __ ] um
director patty jenkins and paul feig you
should just direct
everything cast oprah yeah let's do it
um
okay so uh yeah i would i would say that
um
okay you're talking about near dark
it's weird it's like jason dolan one of
our our our
he's actually a really close friend of
ours but then he's also like a big
top patron person for us he he sent us a
copy of that and i looked it up on
amazon it's like
it's like they rarely make copies of
near dark it's hard to find yeah it's
really crazy and it's a very expensive
copy
and i haven't seen it yet but vampire
genre is my favorite of the supernatural
categories
and i really feel bad for not having
seen it yet but yeah near darker here is
great
appreciate the major super chat i wish
with a super chat at that level we could
really rip on that movie
but um yeah you know what i'm gonna make
it a
i'm gonna make it a an adam and thing
that i do to go watch that film john
stop with the habit let me just put your
hand away let me okay
see this we're gonna do this like they
record new modems
open body language when you're doing
something you're scrolling you've turned
your
your shoulder and back to me and
honestly it just feels like you're
closing me off
i'm being accepted right into your life
scrolling
away from my normal direction of
view another underrated says niraj
krishnan
the descent directed by neil marshall
thank you for your super chat there
narada yeah it's a good ass movie i like
that movie the descent
director of hellboy 2019 and several
game of thrones episodes
actually the descent is very effective i
thought that was going to be a shitty
ass movie
yeah i think the descent is actually
like by the time that that's the crazy
because it's already like scary and it's
claustrophobic cave diving settings and
then when like actual deep like monster
starts showing up
it's it's like goes in hyperdrive that's
a if you guys haven't seen the descent
really recommend it
greg can i break the rules for something
i think you might like
what well i mean nightshade novels
says that let me in is an underrated
film and better than the original in
their opinion
oh yeah no dude let me in yeah wait whoa
vampire film i don't think let me in is
better than let the right one in
but but at least the love of let me in
because you're one of the few people i
know has expressed it
okay let me let the right one in is
one of my top like vampire movies ever
swedish show when they remade it matt
reeves directed it chloe grace moretz
uh stars in it let me in and i think the
remake's all right actually i think it's
a good movie
but let the right one in i think is a
very underrated film
and it's one of those former films i
think more people should have watched
ooh
not bad at all not bad at all who's next
yeah the descent good call narash thank
you for that great call
and ethan holgate ethan holgate thank
you so much buddy
show girls underrated in my opinion yeah
man not gonna lie
definitely dad had a vhs copy of
showgirls
i used to pop it in and skipped certain
scenes in that movie
i am erect why aren't you right i'm
telling you man
showgirls is fun i i barely remember the
actual movie
but i sure remember certain scenes show
girls
yeah takes on a life of its own at a
certain point i've seen the film a timer
or at least time and a half but but yeah
it's part of my life now so yeah it's a
little underrated dude that lap dance
scene
in the in the hot tub no god damn wasn't
everyone talk about that stupid hot tub
scene
the [ __ ] lap dance the actual
laughter the actual
yeah sorry it's great lap dancing guys
oh goodness hey erica tuesday's back in
the
supers just to let us know send you
something on
stream labs love you guys love you too
love you erica we love
your soul some people do the per right
you know like
you need to get the [ __ ] away but that's
not i'm not welcoming you
sorry i was trying to do like a wookiee
sound but you know i just learned to
roll my arse so cut me some
slackage you know it's also underrated
the evil dead remake i gotta say that
it is and somebody pointed out the 2003.
some the same person
pointed out texas jason chase.3d and the
2003 remake
i think the 2003 remake is pretty
underrated i think it's a pretty good
ass horror movie but uh
texas chainsaw 3d is only underrated in
my opinion if you want to
laugh your your ass off because that's a
pretty dumb movie
there's some really ridiculously stupid
[ __ ] in that movie
anisa anisa oliva back in the super
chats thank you dear
she says underrated dodgeball what did
nobody makes me bleed my own blood
he's the most quotable character besides
steve the pirate serving
oh yeah i love dodgeball that's like
i i wish i wish my girlfriend
would watch it with me no the thing is
if you see the trailer for it it looks
like
it is the movie the trailers advertising
but it's
better than what the movie's advertising
that's how i'd put it yeah yeah yeah
like it's actually really funny you know
and as much as i think bench
uh dodgeball is a better movie than
bench warmers i will not
at all deny that when i saw benchwarmers
laughed
pretty funny it's pretty funny and then
she's also saying overrated ace ventura
even though i love jim carrey it was a
little too much for me
okay here's what i'd put as a copy out
of here i know the copy isn't the right
word here's what i just throw in here
ace the term might be overrated
underrated which i think now more people
are liking
the cable guy oh yeah that's kind of
guy's been getting a lot more love it's
come back oh not to break the rules
again but somebody just said the guest
is overrated
the guest is great listen
all right look the guest hasn't been
seen by enough people to be overrated
all right that's a that's a
rad [ __ ] movie oh john we got to
break the super chat so we can hop into
the
to the regular chat we gotta obey okay
guys
really quick where is he mark leach walk
hard
yes one of the most under one of the
most you'll ever see walk hard
that is a smart movie that is like a
really creative
well-ridden comedy and it's like and the
trailers make it look like some silly
lowbrow comedy film when it is not that
that is that is a [ __ ] hysterical
film
and it is smart yeah like that
i wouldn't say it's like for intelligent
audiences but
it's a great comedy speaking of
intelligence though a few people have
said uh in central intelligence is sort
of underrated and uh
that's really funny central that's a
really funny movie i need to see it
actually
that's the best one of kevin hart and
dwayne johnson central intelligence yeah
well all right and uh calvin eaton says
200 rating
i'm split with you here two underrated
movies bumblebee for sure
underrated and uh godzilla king of the
monsters
i think is rated you think so i think
it's rated
because the monster action is great the
human stuff sucks
and yeah you know i think it's just fine
but uh
mark leach also jane levy definitely an
underrated horror actress because she is
she's a great actress in general
and both evil dead and don't breathe
showcase that and in the chat erica
tuesday loves her some [ __ ]
no good yeah um and she says i came out
standing wrong i don't know why
yeah oh uh the uh i saw another one for
the cable guy
ninja assassin as an underrated movie i
think that's
fun i i actually we saw a test screen is
underrated
i haven't seen the theatrical card but
yeah i really really enjoyed the
test screening that we saw of that um
all right
so jock you bring this back yes all
right guys we're gonna be doing the last
rounds of the stream labs and uh the
super chats
but don't worry what's gonna still be
going in here in the regular chat too
children of men i do think is very
underrated um but it's one of my
favorite sci-fi movies of
all time appreciate you saying that
kompuchi one
bumblebee i wish bumblebee had come out
earlier and more people would have seen
it
because that is the best transformers
movie that has been done
so far yeah i'll agree with you there um
eric
horseman jesus mike's terri
thank you but also i am uncomfortable
yeah
thank you for such a major contra thank
you dude it means a lot
too underrated and i agree with your
understanding and a house
of a thousand corpses i really love that
movie
i agree with both of those picks man
oh yeah a house of a thousand corpses
while i
heavily prefer its follow-up the devil's
rejects
i think house of a thousand corpses and
rob zombie had problems with that movie
too
um he's been pretty open about the
issues he had making that movie
he's open about all the issues making
all the movies but uh
but a house of a thousand corpses i
think is actually a really fun cult
movie
and it's a great halloween time movie
100 and slither i think
like is gross that's fine
so fun man that's such a fun movie watch
and i'd say super as well and i think
super talking about james gunn
super as well of james gunn's catalog
i would argue that super is the most
underrated because i feel like slither
at least has
a bigger cult status but uh we got
kb thank you so much eric horseman
seriously i appreciate your generosity
kb i saw mad max because
tom hardy but i was just confused the
whole time
i think maybe i had to know uh i now
think i maybe had to know about a video
game or something before
no i mean maybe the previous maybe the
previous movies to get yourself
oriented in what the world is supposed
to be but
as a film it's pretty contained i think
some people thought that mad max fury
road might be something where you need
to watch the prior installments to get
it
because it's such like a lived-in world
it just throws you into it
yeah um really no you don't like i
remember
i i watched all the mad max movies
leading up to fury road
and then as i was watching fury road
baked out of my mind i was like
i didn't need to watch any of those
movies yeah you really don't know
because i could have easily followed
this you know without it you know
yeah cause that that as a sequel it's
quite episodic
you know uh yeah man so true but thank
you kb
yes don't worry just ask me just ask can
you scroll
down to scroll down would you scroll one
up and then highlight
why do you have an issue asking could
you please
scroll up and then highlight what hitman
hudson our next tipper had to say well
thank you for the tip on streaming labs
here
thank you so much and also yeah okay go
good that's a good placement
uh overrated almost every matthew
mcconaughey movie
i don't know about that uh the t-sip is
not that good of an actor that t-sip is
not that good
an actor also gigan aggies
i don't know i think matthew
mcconaughey's ghost of girlfriends pass
is incredible
failure to launch is another gold is a
classic
planner a sahara oh yeah dude the guys
made some groundbreaking movies now
there are some movies that i think are a
total dog [ __ ]
mud what the [ __ ] was that interstellar
dallas biker confused it wasn't even a
romantic movie
um the lincoln lawyer lawyer jesus
christ ryan philippe stole the show
yeah jesus man and uh true detective
season two is great but season you got a
real season once
you've got a power through season five
season one to get through the great
time is some flat yeah
and it his fake tears in interstellar
again
that reaction video he released during
the time of interstellar
obviously [ __ ] around uh but no i
mean if you think he's overweight i get
i mean
yeah i i i can see you thinking so since
his recent like
explosion into super stardom for sure
anissa in our stream labs here john has
the best smile in the entire world
totally underrated john does have a
great smile
when he smiles he is he has what i call
john the jack nicholson eyebrows like
when he really smiles
his eyebrows are you have very
expressive eyebrows john thanks
yeah you do thanks i learned that from
jack black how's that where you learned
it from
no they've always been a little
expressive but i have been inspired by
jack black's eyebrow game
since then now the way you keep your
trim
your pubes intact where'd you learn that
from
uh watching you know uh pornography
from where we live together yes i would
just be constantly spying being like how
does this man trim
his [ __ ] up well i appreciate the carpet
sit appreciate the stream live
contribution there nissa yeah
um but yes john has a great smile now if
only
you know you you weren't limited on
characters there on text characters you
could have said greg has a great smile
whatever it is greg has
[Music]
life thank you for a really generous uh
tip here buddy zandu is underrated
olivia newton john great uh
elo great 80s outfits and
roller skating excellent great nurses
and gods
[ __ ] great plot line and acting
pretty bad
uh but it ah [ __ ] it's just a fun time
hello oh and jean kelly
you know i haven't seen this
but the way you're i love the way you
left your tip here in your
comment because it's it it sounds like
you were you're
you were dictating it's into a phone
yes but living dan the [ __ ] man i'm i'm
just telling you
like it's great it's so good xanadu's
and zana don'ts
oh that's right sorry i broke the rules
again by looking anywhere other than
this left-hand screen but uh
speaking of eric horstmann's thank you
kiki in the chat that's really sweet of
you and everyone else who's been saying
it
john go tell him okay i interrupted you
i did the thing that i got mad at you
about
but it's different because i can be a
hypocrite you can't
you need to better yourself first a lot
of mistakes first off
kiki i braided my hair which is why john
please we're trying to
stick to the streamlabs yes what are you
doing uh
focus here to eric horstmann's previous
comment
erica just commented baby firefly in the
house
and that's actually how we met is uh she
was playing baby firefly in a house of a
thousand corpses maze
at the universal studios so uh i'm erica
when she was working
on cam4ultimate.com that's a specific
name
uh you know hey man sex work is work not
that
yeah i'm not gonna corroborate that
story but but you know do what you gotta
do to make your money
we got soul scarecrow okay there's
people who even love to the [ __ ] uh
zondo movie here dude xanadu is a
cult especially among musical heads it's
a cult classic also
i've seen some elysium love just happy
about any neil blom camp love
every movie following district nine
by neo blom campus is underrated
everything that man has touched besides
in fact somebody said in the chat that
district 9 was underrated as much as i
wanted to be like sure why not
i was also like it's the one movie of
his people
unanimously respect don't worry dan
jones one day you will meet us allison
harding thinks once upon a time in
hollywood's overrated
yeah sure maybe we gotta watch santa
dude thank you eric horseman very sweet
of you
soul skirt j9 underrated breakdown 1997
with kurt russell
oh [ __ ] is that the one on the plane no
that's executive decision
what is he the president i don't
remember right now oh
yes solster j you named a movie that is
so underrated it was my first jim cavizo
film
frequency yes no one has ever cited a
movie as being their first jim caviezel
film have you seen his frequency i have
not
i should it's an old-time like radio
communication device
his dad died when he was a little boy in
a fire
and then he's able to talk to his dad in
present day
but the radio was connecting him to his
dad in the past
oh that's cool i like that yeah oh
that's so good
i'm down with that so good and it's
intense frequency you guys should watch
it
[ __ ] kind of monte cristo frequency
why is there a competition between the
two um
erica i was just revealing the truth
the truth is what the hell that was no
erica's never done that
no i i agree um well we got one more
take my career advice i'm sorry you
would have done great there
let me let me grab this for just a
technical a technical second and pull
this down
okay now you can go back embrace your
geekness
is the last uh current when did i first
meet erica
it's been a it's been a handful how did
i first meet eric because erica tuesday
in the chat is a really close friend of
john's
didn't you come to one of one of her
borough parties i first met her when she
had an opening
for uh like a big event uh it was a good
show was it google ghost
yes that's what it was yeah that's when
i first met her for your birthday
i was very intimidated because i was
like holy [ __ ] this woman's very
talented
yeah yeah yeah so then i i resort to
jokes like this to deflect my
insecurities over your success i'm sorry
here because
um damn someone just shouted out snatch
was a movie that i still want to see
that you
like turned me on to years ago yes
and then uh what else did you say here
clint eastwood
loved this show guys thanks for the last
of course i'll scare jay oh
dennis a true crime what erica where are
you going is erica really mad at me
no erica don't leave john call erica
olivia is awake from her nap and she is
saying
underrated age films the lady vanishes
and the 39 steps
39 stops oh yeah
let's see here uh embrace your geekness
yes let's see here under
ooh ooh underrated dogma
overrated the lost boys
congrats to both of you on your inner
geekdom matches in the movie trivia
oh thank you so much thank you so much
we did all right we did all right
i don't know i mean i haven't seen dogma
honestly i you know what i really like
from kevin smith is horror movies
what i like red state and [ __ ]
yeah i really like those movies
overrated the lost boys
um i guess so
um i've i guess
i've personally i feel like the lost
boys is is like
rated but i could i could give you that
i mean
you know it is a beloved if you travel
in the horror circles especially people
who love the 80s
the lost boys i think is one that comes
up right away
or or one of the first ones to come up
so uh yeah i'm going to
text erica right now oh no
i love that too because you i saw the
screen and you wrote i'm going to and
yeah it's really hard to text while
you're talking and not but i'm not going
to say what i like i'm not going to say
because this is personal
it's okay it's okay it's okay i can look
at the chat for a moment yeah the thing
is
the thing was underrated when it first
came out but is it underrated now i feel
like the thing is
really caught up um but let's see here
underrated the polar express interesting
31 by rob
zombie i'm a fan um
what are some more choices all right so
where are we at here but yeah i mean
have you seen the lost boys yeah
yeah my pops worked on that movie your
dad worked on the lost boys
really yeah your dad has worked on so
many great movies thanks
who's your dad he's your daddy
he's joe schumacher
who's your daddy and what does he do i
don't know man all right
let's go back to here let's see what's
going on here
um john how do you bring this back oh
i'm sorry
you wanna yeah let's get the santa let's
do a little reload just in case
and a title overlay's gone and here
we're back at the
super chats uh i don't know what our
next topic will be kiki gardner
niraj is back he says the notebook
overrated
i've not seen the notebook i think the
notebook
is you know there was
yeah i i mean i don't know i i recognize
all the dumb things about the notebook
yet i also think the notebook is is like
i i really get swept up in it despite
knowing how like ridiculous it is
and how like i wrote you a letter every
day for the last year or some [ __ ] or
whatever the [ __ ]
that's a lot of people
after a certain amount of time you'd be
like what the [ __ ] do i
uh what do i talk like what would you
write for a whole year straight you know
just just the same letter yeah i love
you
i miss you i wish we could beat you
talking about like the most random [ __ ]
i wish you didn't have whatever like
ailment is affecting our love
that's more but uh i i recognize how
ridiculous
it is um but but
uh i still get swept up in it and i do
think the chemistry between rachel
mcadams and
ryan gosling is [ __ ] dynamite in that
film oh yeah oh yeah
underrated oh anissa is back thank you
anisa this will be the last round of
super chats then we gotta
go and we'll take some quick speed
rounds of the ones in the real
chat so we're gonna do a speed round
here all right anissa says underrated
ford v
ferrari also the art of racing in the
rain such great movies people need to
talk about them more i really really
liked uh ford v ferrari a lot did not
get to see chasing
uh the art of racing in the rain
unfortunately with uh the cat from
uh this is us uh we uh 4v ferrari
made me cry mm-hmm i was actually swept
up by fort viewferrar a lot and i feel
like a lot of people talk about the
technical aspects of maybe christian
bale's performance
in 4v ferrari but i was genuinely like
swept up in that film
and i like the ken miles storyline
actually did bring me to tears there
yeah it's a really and i got mad at the
end dude i didn't know the true story
and i got
mad with that film yeah i feel like
that's an example of a recent film that
is just
so well made that whether or not you're
interested in racing you can still get
into
very true yeah it's like it's so punchy
it's got such energy in life
mandy ballard keep it up
thank you for the sticker i love the
stickers thank you mandy ballard
all about them sticks ooh okay i gotta
say this one quietly then
hmm greg greg please don't show this to
olivia but overrated gone with the wind
olivia will get me to like it but
the longest four hours of my life
i can see why you feel that way but you
know i i
i think gone with the wind is the
greatest gone with the wind is one of
the best movies of all time
ever it's my favorite
is underrated um any arm wrestling
motion pictures underrated
and then but okay but thank you
thank you anissa and then what do we got
peter pacheco peter pacheco's back
marvel related underrated
thor overrated captain marvel
i don't think i see the i mean
appreciate the super chat but but i
don't feel like captain marvel's
overrated
if anything i feel like it qualifies
more under the underrated department i
mean it made a [ __ ] ton of money but i
feel like it's actually underrated
i feel like even though i don't love it
but i feel like it is you know yeah just
for the
the hate storm that followed that and uh
thor
i think the first thor is underrated i
think it's a little underrated i feel
like everyone's like thor didn't get
good till [ __ ] uh ragnarok ragnarok
but i think the first door is actually
pretty
pretty decent i don't think it's great
but i think it's all right and i i
and i don't i i think that's it's become
even more appreciated over time
definitely that's what i'm saying one of
my favorite mcu jokes is in the first
thor movie
which one's that another
beautiful bliss thank you for the thumb
up thank you beautiful blisters very
kind
sticker right there much aprice uh
mosin zamen man of steel
underrated for sure followed by a
redacted comment
well we appreciate the super chats buddy
but like i said at the very top of this
i do think man of steel is actually
underrated but has been getting the love
it finally truly has earned my
girlfriend wouldn't agree oh man that
but i think man of steel is actually a
total blast of a film
i don't know about blast but i think
it's actually really good yeah
but thank you whoa did we just get like
a whole bunch more super chat the [ __ ]
just happened
no it's just that it it it just
when it when it scrolls yeah all right
all right uh verdugo
silver overrated forrest gump underrated
dark city
and children of men verdugo silver thank
you for saying
did you see dark city with me yeah yeah
we watched it i appreciate you saying
dark city because i
i think that's a cool movie it just kind
of got lost somewhere
whereas a dark city is actually like the
the
the scope of it the cinematography the
production design the the world that's
built is [ __ ]
amazing and i i actually really like the
ending reveal too the end of reveal like
surprised me
and uh so yeah i think it gets
overshadowed by the matrix mostly
because of the the proximity
um i mean it just came out i mean
there's like there's there's there's
the 13th floor dark city and the matrix
yeah yeah and uh and the matrix got like
the
the spotlight right but 13th floor and
dark city were two movies that were in a
similar category to the matrix or that
came out around the same time and i
think they're all good
um also i will definitely go in with you
guys in the chat uh sleepy hollow is one
of my favorite tim burton films
definitely underrated does he get hate
i don't think he gets hate but i don't
think it gets raped either
really yeah that's [ __ ] bizarre yeah
we got
anissa's back uh thank you anisa
underrated idol hands such a great
horror comedy
i've never seen it have you i've seen a
good amount of it yeah i haven't seen it
all the way through
uh but yeah i thought it was pretty fun
the parts i saw and uh
you know we got a little a little
tenuous connection to the director
thereof so that's a fun
fact for y'all um i'd like to say in the
chat
that someone is saying blade runner is
underrated
i think that is a very overrated sci-fi
movie
i'm just saying i prefer 2049
by like way way more i'll just say that
all right i i i really do prefer that
um but i appreciate the opinion you got
we got diamond dogs puppy in here next
overrated memento
underrated basketball basketball diaries
is a movie i've heard about over the
the years and especially again lately
and i feel like that's a movie i need to
check out what is that
i don't know but everybody says it's
under a movie i think
maybe but i keep hearing it's an
underrated film like
it's good and that it doesn't get its
due so um you must be right
i you know i it's been a long time since
i've seen memento
but i'm kind of wondering if i'll meet
you on on that
if memento is overrated because um
with memento uh
with memento i think a lot of people
talk about the structure of that movie
than they do the actual movie
and they're so impressed with the way
how it goes backwards and [ __ ] but i
rarely hear people talk about the actual
movie itself
and even for myself when i saw it i was
like this is a [ __ ] crazy-ass unique
structure
um i'm i'm kind of curious as for myself
like
maybe that's like a a similar a similar
thing
yeah yeah for sure oh we got some more
dread 3ds in the main chat
uh who's next on here uh niraj
underrated event horizon and everybody
wants some
you know event horizon is one that i've
also heard people talk about in recent
years as far as like sci-fi horror goes
and i feel like that is one of the few
paul w s anderson movies that might get
legitimate respect
right right and everybody wants some is
a movie i want to see actually i'm a big
link later
fan and i feel like when that came out
it didn't seem like it made as big of a
splash as being a sequel to dazed and
confused
theoretically ought to how do people put
chats on pauses i really need to go to
the bathroom
i don't know i mean i've just been
taking to like leaving one of these
windows scrolled part way and then it
kind of freezes
what if i wanted to go to the bathroom
what is the way i
handle this situation if i need to go to
the bathroom i mean you could just let
me rant about the hobbit series for a
minute on niraj's next
would it be all right with you guys if i
went to the bathroom and came back in
like two minutes dude do your thing man
and then i'll come
to the bathroom right now we're at 130
concurrent viewers
yes and let's see how well you can
maintain this in the meantime
okay all right okay thanks john no
problem
tag teammate man underrated machine gun
preacher gerard butler
that's a mark forster movie which i
would like to see i would i would say
that uh
mark forster by the way because i've
seen a lot of world war
z in this chat i've also seen his movie
stay
which i can understand why you would
think is a bit pretentious or whatever
it is a little figurative it is a little
obtuse but i like that movie and it's a
ryan gosling joint i believe as well
uh and maybe even mcgregor i feel like
oh
tv kiki gardner oh there's plenty i mean
the thing is like the topics
it depends really on how much verve
there is
for the um uh
you know like the specificity of the
movies but you know overrated underrated
in general
by all means why not underrated the void
james wright that's a movie i gotta see
i've heard it owes a debt of gratitude
to john carpenter
for certain uh yeah get a bottle and pee
in it that's what i've been thinking of
doing but you know uh
i don't know if youtube would be super
happy about that hi
sorry it's just me now underrated i am
legend you know what
i like i am legend i don't i to me
personally i guess i would say it's it's
rated
uh just because you know yeah that's
right welcome to john's corner
this is i actually back in the day when
i was still jerry
and we were still ryan and jerry i
wanted to do a segment called jerry's
horror corner
it was all about oh horror yeah greg's
bladder is overrated so is mine though
especially you know i've got this thing
going on so uh yeah
underrated solo
or the 120 days of sodom or whatever
that
that that is oh goodness gracious me
that's
sure why not necromantic is also
underrated as is a serbian film and the
human centipede part
two uh stay tuned with john ritter i
don't know if i know that movie you're
next that's a good
horror flick uh the croods i'm
surprised to have seen as many times in
this chat just because uh yeah i never
would have expected the croods
i feel like there are a lot of animated
movies though that you could throw out
that i wouldn't have expected
yes cocaine jesus cocaine jesus we still
talked to tyrone
in fact he's been doing some great uh
coverage lately
i mean you know he's always great with
his you know pop culture stuff but he's
been doing some great coverage lately on
just uh black lives matter
and just the different news reports
coming out and so if you want
you know a voice of color to check out
in relation to what's going on in the
world i think he's been especially
killing it in that side of things i have
not seen edge of 17
um there was no superman but christopher
reeve
because superman returns was directed by
brian singer
uh yeah you know i'll i'll allow that
for sure
um let's see let's see stay
tuned yeah we're just talking overrated
buckaroo
bonsai now
i mean i can understand you feeling that
way among the people who are buckaroo
banzai fans
but but like i don't feel like enough
people know what that movie is for it to
be underrated so you know leave your
thoughts but uh
i'm just glad to see somebody name
checking it at all
no martyrs is a is a horror film i i
need to see
the original sorry the original
not the blumhouse free remake
which uh you know i used to work at
blumhouse i got love for them but but
i've heard that remake is pretty poor uh
yeah
rip rest in peace ian holm for sure that
guy has had a
incredibly long and storied career i
mean he's been in so many things
obviously bilbo lord of the rings uh and
um what is his name ash in aliens but
he's been in so much an
alien sorry but he's been in so much
stuff
all right i'm gonna go take a bathroom
break i'll be right back enjoy the
viewers went up
while i was gone john johnson holding
the [ __ ] down
where are we at all right we're just
going to there's a normal chat right now
all right what do we got here guys
what's up
all right do you like the punisher 2004
with thomas james michael ware in the
chat is saying
i do like that one man and i think
thomas jane actually the [ __ ] dirty
laundry short film that
thomas jane did was um
a little bit better than the actual 2004
movie that we got uh but i really like
that one too
and uh let's see hello well i am happy
to be back
hey tm what's going on dude and
uh cocaine jesus and the jesus christ
what a [ __ ] name
is it i mean is it cocaine jesus cause
i'm reading it like cocaine jesus which
sounds like wonderfully offensive am i
the only one who thought christian bale
was a bad batman i don't think you're
the only one who thought that dude
i actually think christian bale was
probably the best bruce wayne
that there's ever been um i could
understand if you don't think he's the
best
batman per se but i think in terms of
bruce wayne
i think he's pretty [ __ ] incredible
brianno three is asking in the chat
yeah i like justice league i do i like
the weeding cut
but i'm also exceptionally excited for
the snyder cut i really [ __ ] am i'm
very excited for that
underrated the last samurai scott
edwards says in the chat
is it underrated i mean i feel like it
was a pretty popular movie you know what
i mean
horror and gamer is uh hey graham i
asked you to be interested in reacting
to my music video i made
a collage what is your collage of or did
you make it in college is that what
you're saying
uh nightshade novels in the chat is
saying some kind of wonderful is the
best
john hughes movie ever so underrated
um yeah i've never seen some kind of
wonderful i find it funny now that in
the time we're living and so many people
are bringing up how problematic john
hughes movies have been
uh or actually are which i find to be
pretty amusing
um but hey i mean that's just it's weird
when you see movies that were like so
beloved but as they start
that's why so i was saying earlier in
this stream like i'm surprised that
scott pilgrim versus the world
still gets so much love and i actually
like i see the problem with it that some
people have addressed with me
of like the fact that scott pilgrim's
dating a 17 year old at the beginning of
the movie
yet hey what's up dude yeah yeah yeah
was much faster than me
mine was when i was gone i made it look
like i was trying to take like a super
fast poop when really i just really had
to go to the bathroom
oh damn i'm sorry um
we're back in action looney tunes looney
tunes haven't seen uncut gems yet and we
were soldiers mark leech
yes very underrated war movie
all right john let's bring this back
shall we let us we
shall alrighty it's super chat time
with niraj krishnan
overrated the hobbit series no no no no
you missed it oh you missed it all right
i'm sorry unless you handle the super
chat without me being here which is
[ __ ] up i thought we talked about
event horizon no we didn't some yes we
did we talked about memento
and basketball diaries well event
horizon is uh
arguably one of the more agreeable paul
w s anderson films i feel like that
movie
uh maybe a little smudge underrated you
know where my anger comes from with
event horizon
we missed a five pointer question in the
showdown when the answer was
interstellar
and uh john was like is it event horizon
and i trusted john
the king of the showdown i know i feel
plain
for trusting you for misleading you
uh for just putting in my brain at the
time
but everybody wants some do you know
what that is yeah it's the richard
linklate we talked about this this is
the
shirt yes i don't think we did i was
surprised everybody wants some didn't do
as well as it could have given that it's
a richard linklater movie and i think an
uh something of a sequel to dazed and
confused right so uh
i want to see it i'm sorry that it was
underrated i feel like it kind of came
and went when it when it came out so
you know and now overrated
the hobbit series from niraj christian
raj is saying that
i feel like the hobbit series if
anything would go under the underrated
category
if anything i think it's really he likes
those movies some people really like
those movies i know that but
yeah but i i've rarely met the person
who does
i haven't met the person and when they
say they like the hobbit movies it's
usually
set up like this you know what i
actually like the hobbit
well aware always goes into that like
sure i like the hobbit movies so i don't
really know who
who really enjoys those films but all
right
um let's see here
dream chaser back to i was happy to see
you back in the chat
hi guys underrated man of steel this is
the most thanks for the super chat by
the way this is the most talked about
underrated movie this entire live stream
i know i started it but it also
seems like more and more people are
chiming in talking about how
man of steel is uh like extremely
underrated and
i feel like that feeling of it being
underrated has catapulted it to being a
lot more in the spotlight as of late too
okay that's fair i am definitely i think
it's one of the more agreeable dceu
flicks
uh at least since the more recent wave
of well-agreeable films fair enough
fair enough ooh byzantium i'm seeing in
the chat
transformer i like the first
transformers movie fifth element
red red two strangers fray at night
the tables game welcome to the chat here
hello hello
eric horseman i'm asking you to stop
super chatting all right
i don't i don't want to i've been
starting to feel like you got to be
careful you got to be mindful i know
about your job situation i appreciate
all the support but i'm asking
you but thank you dude he says uh i mean
we'll read it anyway thank you for your
super chat buddy
remy and michelle's high school reunion
underwriter
oh i've seen that in theaters funniest
movie ever
period need a sequel like bill and ted
wait a minute you saw it in the theaters
how
yeah i saw a revival screening of romy
and michelle
at the ace theater who did you go with
uh my friend haley took me
she was through a theater company she
was working with at the time and uh yeah
they did a screening at the ace theater
and hotel where i also saw putney
swope with robert downey senior oh
really
yes uh yeah that's cool that's a good
movie i always think when i think of
remy michelle my mind for some reason
always goes to the sweetest thing with
cameron diaz and christina applegate
when that's not the same movie
no but there are two women at the center
right so
same difference i'm just kidding i'm not
they're not the same um but yeah i guess
more people should be watching that
all right hey anis oliva has a question
here for john thank you my dear
john how does it feel being 3d well it's
pretty good
i'm tired of being flat um nah uh the
big three
it's good it's all right it's it's we've
been in quarantine so it's not been the
birthdayest
birthday
to every birthday but uh you know i feel
i feel decent i feel like uh you know
this decade
has a better rep than the 20s did so i'm
looking forward to that
um all right beautiful bliss and another
sticker
and it's like a little birthday cake
it's a little cake slice
uh where are we i lost our spot john we
are down
further we are down further we are down
further
we're almost there
oh my god you too so eric has just said
hi
nissa in the super chat and then anissa
says hi eric and i'm that's
i love how you guys will have a
conversation
when really you you could just like
message each other on instagram but we
appreciate it
we appreciate everything
um anise is saying thank you anisa also
i feel like when you all would really
enjoy
awesome being during sxsw if you all
don't know what that is
look it up have you all ever been to
coachella i flirt in the chat all the
time with john
that you do um
no i mean sxsw is a film festival event
and we've
gotten like early access to movies
because of it yeah yeah
i've never been to the event i'd love to
go to south by and honestly
coachella i don't think i'd ever do that
it just sounds like a very icky
uncomfortable experience
well and south by southwest doesn't seem
quite as sweaty and oppressed like i
know it
it would probably be a gruel if you want
to catch everything
but it doesn't seem quite as grueling as
coachella does uh
you know and us also you know movie
oriented so you're not outside the
entire time
yeah um but i would love to go to south
by yeah i would love to check it out
uh would you go to coachella i wanted to
but the thing is
i feel like coachella the the peak of
when i should have gone has already
passed because there was a year where
like
all of my f it was like queens and stone
age gorillas
uh one of jack white's bands and a bunch
of other i was like all of my favorites
are playing and since then you know i've
never seen as good of a lineup in
in my tastes you know yeah uh opinions
so
i might go but i'm not like champing at
the bit any longer to go
i just feel like i'd be stressed out and
have a headache the whole time
i it seems like it's hard to get to a
place where you're not worried about the
elements
you know or distracted by the elements i
mean if i i
i think my days of wanting to take
ecstasy are behind me and i feel like
maybe if i wanted to take
ecstasy i could enjoy myself but i don't
think i'd want to take ecstasy now
with the kind of human being i am now
interesting
well that's good to know about yourself
and we'll let a silence go there as you
all don't try drugs
stay in school kids eric horseman's back
happy pride
to any lgbtq i plus plus plus happy
pride month for sure
happy pride happy juneteenth happy pride
oh yeah oh yeah happy pride
it's pride month um
eric i talked with eric on patreon about
uh pride month and he says
and uh it's what i really admire about
what happened recently with like the
march
the gay pride march uh was that they
didn't they
there's some st i don't know if it's
like everywhere but there's some state
who like
turned it also into like a black lives
matter march as well yeah
there have been a few that have co-opted
and yeah i know that on hollywood
between highland and la brea they have
painted
on the street and they have some of it
blocked off they have had it blocked off
for like a week now
um uh all all black lives matter in
various colors
um you know to kind of encompass the
lgbtq part of that uh community as well
so uh yeah there are a few places i've
seen
i think washington dc has it painted
into the streets and a few other cities
as well
so it's it's pretty inspiring well i'm
glad to have you here
eric my beautiful gay friend who one day
you will get a dick pic from me i swear
or i'll get it from you you're eric
horseman it's bound to happen when
you're drunk
knowing eric horseman it's bound to
happen when you're drunk and i will
gladly accept that from you buddy
ryan c is next the nice guys
is very underrated thank you ryan c for
your stupid agreed
the nice guys is a very witty comedy
and i like it more than kiss kiss bang
bang and i feel like that's probably not
a common opinion but i actually prefer
it over a kiss kiss bang bang
i mean [ __ ] ryan gosling is just
absolutely hysterical in it man he's so
funny he's so funny and i think both of
them together are great too and i feel i
don't know why but
there's something about uh the nice guys
that has a touch more heart for me
than than kissing 100 yeah yeah for sure
so
respect to both but yeah i love the nice
guys that was like such a breath of
fresh air when it dropped
and niraj is saying here hey thank you
niraj
hey frequency is considered underrated
then hannah is also
both ended up getting a tv show fair
point i did not know frequency got a tv
i shouldn't either
no are any of these shows are still
alive
did it how long are these shows still
existing
john are you yawning during a live
stream i know
it's because i was trying to think of
hannah still is
still on at amazon is hannah through
amazon
uh yes
was it good i never heard beyonce i'm
not sure to be honest
cube is an underrated sci-fi frequency
got a tv show
actually i could see how make a tv show
out of both did they make a
tv show out of the treadstone world is
there a show called treadstone
making i don't know if it's premiered
but yeah i was in the works or is in the
works or something i don't know
yeah they they want that boring
franchise to keep on milking
well jeremy renner's your key to aaron
cross anisa is saying thank you anisa
john i want to meet your dad and just
hear all of the stories he has
can't even imagine pretty soon you'll be
able to hear some stories
god damn my dad was just on a podcast
talking about the thing
with a few other people including like
dean cundy who shot the movie and some
of the actors and stuff and
or maybe with some of the effects depart
either way you can you can hear that and
when it's out i'll let you know
do you ever go to your dad and go papa
can you tell me a story about being on
set of the thing
no because i haven't had to lately
because it's been on enough that he's
just been telling them which is great
which is awesome but so now you're like
papa
can you shut the [ __ ] up about the thing
for just one second i'm trying to watch
this film i've seen
i just want to enjoy dinner please stop
telling me about your
your past experiences with john
carpenter that's right
that's right you know what i think it's
an underrated movie because in the chat
richard said you're the gun i would say
way of the gun um oh my god christopher
mcquarrie
directed that movie not bad really yeah
the christopher mcquarrie of tom cruise
fame mm-hmm
damn not bad good for him glad he's
moving on up in the past
uh thank you cocaine jesus for all the
comments here scott
edwards is next would y'all consider the
arrowverse crossover event
movies and are y'all excited for the
next one
what does that mean would you all thank
you for the super chat by the way would
you all consider the arrow
verse crossover event movies what does
that mean would you consider
that event a movie or movies
if there are multiple arrowverse
crossovers as underrated or overrated or
are you saying would we consider
watching it because of course i'd watch
it well i think it's just would you
consider those as being like
miniature movies made for tv that's how
i'm taking it would you consider these
events to be their own little event
movies
i don't know and would you be excited
for the next i know i wouldn't
buy creative gaming but yeah i mean i i
feel the arrowverse
they designed the aeroverse crossovers
in a way where even if you're not
watching the show
they're gonna throw in so much
expositional dialogue that they don't
have time for scenes to breathe
so that way anyone who's not even
watching the other shows can still keep
up with this [ __ ] with this crossover
event
so i think that even if you don't watch
the shows you might be a little cut loss
they can't cover everything but they
cover enough where if you even like
casually keep up with [ __ ] you can still
watch those
but thank you and of course i'm always
excited for the next crossover event
from them
brandon wallace brought up one i was
going to name
underrated yes underrated thank you
sunshine by danny boyle
cloud atlas and the thin red line by
terence malik
dude sunshine sunshine i love that movie
i know you do
i watch because of you yeah and you know
i mean
i understand what's to be complained
about but i think as far as danny boyle
flicks go i mean it's definitely one of
my favorites from him and it's a movie
that's always stuck with me so i'd say
that's an underrated flick
um cloud atlas we did talk about thin
red line
i saw when i was a kid i they really
should have censored me
oh also by the way don't do not worry
about it in the least
nightshade you're welcome to dislike the
thing
and i won't be mad andrew cook thank you
for your super chat
inception is extremely overrated it's
technical aspects are amazing but the
characters are so one-dimensional
i might have to agree with you on that i
i would certainly
say that that that characters are not
the
the first and foremost focal point of
that movie so i can
certainly understand why yeah they would
be a little thin i really
like inception i really like it a lot
but when the more i re-watch it
it doesn't really get better for me
okay it's kind of just it's just full or
becomes less interesting but it doesn't
get worse
i would say it doesn't like i watch it
every time i'm like oh never mind this
movie's actually [ __ ]
it just i i i don't
i feel like i don't know there's
something like the first time i watched
it i was blown away
and the second time i went i loved it so
much i went to the theaters to watch it
again
and then i was like that was cool yeah
i don't know what it was yeah i was i
was kind of surprised by how much
like i wasn't as swept up at all the
second time i watched it
you know but i feel like you can deal
with other ones yeah good luck
what the [ __ ] is going on dude kiki and
daniel in the chat are about to hook up
oh good
way to go daniel this is what we do we
bring people together yeah also a coin
kid
big fan of the lonely island um let's
see here
uh andrew cook we got a nesa next uh
anissa says
john we would love we would all love
you to do a horror corner oh yeah while
you were out there
i brought up jerry's horror corner yeah
which um which i haven't actually
discounted especially because uh
i've got a new series of videos i've
been working on for uh patreon
um that has been thrown off by just the
state of the world a little bit but one
thing i wanted to do was actually just
work a segment into
that called horror corner in case there
was any sort of news or
special thoughts about the horror world
that you know were on my mind because uh
it percolates all year and not just
during halloween time so don't count it
out it might show up pretty soon
all right then yeah hey al hey alex in
the chat what's up
yo yo yo alex karen i believe that's
um is that lexi looks like her right
i've never known her to go by alex so i
i never i sort of don't think it's her
which alex is this
i feel like we know this alex alex do we
know you
i feel like we met this hour are we i'm
not sure
which alex clarify for that an allison
machine gun preacher is one of gerard
butler's few good films
yeah probably quantitatively so and it's
a mark foster joint
and then anissa is also saying i had
edibles for the first time
in february in vegas it was interesting
it just made me
really chill and i just laughed a lot
ha ha then i got sleepy
man that sounds like a really dull
in the chat oh we haven't met alex you
look familiar i'm sorry
but thanks for being here alex we're
about to end this yeah
i thought that was uh i thought that was
lexi uh [ __ ] uh alexi pasquerella
yeah i thought that's who it was
no unfortunately no i don't know her but
it's okay
unfortunately it's somebody who's
established that it's a new alex also
cedric
underrated friday the 13th 2009 i do
think
is highly underrated that movie gets way
more [ __ ] than it deserves it's
just as good as half the sequels that's
fair well there yeah i mean i won't say
it's the best of the series but there
are a lot of like friday the 13th die
hards were like [ __ ] up movie and i'm
like you like jason goes to hell it's
not as bad as that
all right uh but yeah dude i once i mean
anissa going off the
since you're the last super chat of the
day going off of that one
i i once had a terrible edible
experience where i had like 100
milligrams of edibles
and i was at a bar and i was in the
the smoking area and i really i mean i
tell the story a lot but it's true i i
i thought i was in gotham but i wasn't
like
batman in gotham i was just like a
civilian in gotham
and it was [ __ ] terrifying because
why would you want to be in
gotham yeah
you're not batman and gotham is no point
in being in gotham
i thought i saw a catwoman crawling on
the wall uh it was a really
trippy ass experience why do people live
here why do people live in gotham
oh we got one more super chat here then
we got some stream laps yeah
yeah we got we got one or two more
stream labs and as of now
one more super chat so we're we're in
the home stretch party peeps
just love you guys hi to olivia and
happy juneteenth we have to do better
talking to white peeps you're exempt i'm
exempt
i need to do better you need to do
better [ __ ] yeah man yeah no
seriously if you don't know what
juneteenth is please go
google it you'll find it exactly yeah
yeah exactly but uh
thank you very much celebration and it
should be an
uh national holiday for sure and eric
you're the bomb
love the hell out of you and uh yeah
all right so john let's refresh this and
we'll do the last
round do the last round of these super
chats
yeah looky there looky there going to
town
behind the curtains sulks soul skier
uh 1999 breakdown is
oh no it's not i'm ahead of myself look
at that
uh eric horstmann eric was here under
[ __ ] raided nightbreed
clive barker buddy worked on the
director's cut of that movie and it's
all he would talk about for a year
knight braid is underrated uh clyde
barker is underrated
i haven't seen knight breed but i
appreciate the the stream vibe donation
do you are you a big clyde barker fan me
yeah i like clyde barker a lot i don't
have as much experience as i would like
to but uh the several joints of his i've
seen i think he has a very
distinct sensibility and of all the 80s
classic horror films that i saw
hellraiser was the one that matched
my outside expectations of how intense
and
scary one of those films would be like
friday the 13th or nightmare on elm
street even halloween
i was like you know big respect for
these movies i really enjoyed them but
uh hellraiser was just as
messed up as i was expecting and i think
clive barker's perspective is really
fascinating because he brings a lot of
the gothic
he's also got a lot of the um
just sort of darker uh i don't know he
does really gothic dark and somewhat
sort of sexual stuff
that is interesting in a way that i
think a lot of other horror movies don't
approach it from
so yeah clive barker uh respect for me i
like him a lot man you really light up
when you talk about horror
i love horror i know it's just so
fascinating i love horror it's really
difficult
that you'll be like so short in all
these other ones but then the second we
talk about something horror
you just can't like shut up i know
that's crazy
shut the [ __ ] up
um let's see let's go really quick we'll
do a quick speed round here
why gotham greg i don't know and cedric
thanks for taking off work
have not seen the lodge have you seen
the lodge no but i've it's been
recommended
trippy right i've heard it's cool yeah
riley q um
let's see here love you too kiki have a
good night
and uh okay let's wrap let's see okay
okay
thank you of course anissa is saying oh
greg has the brightest soul brightest
soul i don't know about that man
i just offended a friend of ours oh i
mean erica
i feel terrible for real i really do i'm
not going to go all [ __ ] public
about like to public because i mean it
happened here
and i made a joke and you can do the
replay and i [ __ ] uh offended her and
now i feel like [ __ ] terrible about
it
i feel terrible um because i don't know
i used to make
jokes like that all the time and i still
make jokes like that a lot
guys girls the the webcam one oh
yeah oh i really offended her i missed
it oh [ __ ] well i know i feel bad about
it
i really do we'll figure it out yeah and
so
i don't know uh so i can't agree with
you that i have the brysol
see you do have a braids i mean i i feel
bad though
you know well you know i mean you've got
a sense of humor that every now and
again gets you into hot water but you're
so so
it's your house i mean you know your
soul and heart are bright and luminous
and resilient i appreciate that john but
at the same time
you know i do i feel like it's one of
those things where
i make a lot of jokes and then sometimes
i cross the line
and rare is the day where i'm like go
[ __ ] yourself
i made a joke sometimes i make a joke
just to provoke just to offend people
and then suddenly i'm like oh i feel bad
yeah yeah yeah
like why would i do that to myself hey
you know
i feel like i don't know i just feel bad
it's the game it's on my mind i'm not
gonna lie it's on my
mind like this whole uh for over a good
amount of that's been on my mind oh
so yeah i really you gotta get see but
that's just evidence of your good soul
no but no not as it sounds like a
[ __ ] thing that i'm just saying here
yeah
yeah i'm here to say otherwise yeah i do
i do
i feel feel pretty bad about i tried
calling her when i went to the bathroom
oh
soul scare 1999 and uh
yeah you know oh [ __ ] there's a way for
the day when a guy gets offended
if i make a sex joke at him you know i
feel like most of the guys play along
i've had a guy i've heard one guy in the
chat be like that's [ __ ] gross dude
i've had one guy saying yeah but you
know but i'm waiting for the day where's
the guy gets really mad at me
yeah well you know just start talking
about dick
i've done it but you know especially if
it's a girl and a female and a female
friend
uh that that made that just always gets
to me like really bad if it's especially
if it's a female friend yeah
guy from be like sorry bro what's up
let's high five
high five and everything is fixed female
friend i'm like ah [ __ ] i [ __ ] up
you know uh but don't say too much i've
been knowing this i've listened to a lot
of dave chappelle
bill burr and joe rogan here like this
is so much them and i feel like that's
why so many sex shows have been coming
back in my
life oh at least you know where to trace
i listen to too many comedians of this
certain brand and then i start
[ __ ] doing jokes like them um but
thank you anisa sorry you said that and
i totally deflected the compliment
best hair and the biggest muscles in the
entire world not true at all in the
muscles i've definitely gotten weaker
one better than the gym today
best hair though best hair in the game
not true john's got the best
everyone knows that you got the curls my
boy so scared jer
1999 uh break uh thank you anissa and
still screwed jared
says breakdown is kurt russell trying to
find his kidnap wife from a creepy
trucker
after their car breaks great flick
modernist hitchcock vibes
uh well from 1997. i've never heard of
this [ __ ] movie breakdown
and i i love a lot of hey good night
guys whoever's saying good night
but i've never [ __ ] heard of this
movie no i haven't either as a matter of
fact
and i feel like i mean it's weird if
they're famous directors i feel like
there are less excuses not to know their
films but if you're just a famous actor
there are like tons of films that you
might
never have heard of right right and uh
so yeah this makes me very curious
actually because uh yeah
kidnapped wife from a creepy trucker
like that sounds like one of those
is this the sa yes oh no this is 90s
okay if this was the 70s i would be very
confident i'd be like yeah let's watch
this
it's the 90s i would be like let's let's
see how it is
the 90s is a tricky decade for things
holding up well
um okay so hey kiki gardner in the chat
i just want to let you know
you got to be careful man you don't want
to be giving out that information yeah
be careful yo how
how old owl do you first off how old are
you secondly
um like you gotta you gotta be like
[ __ ] careful you don't wanna be
giving out that [ __ ] in the street
there's gotta be a way to like delete
your your comment of
your email holy [ __ ] that's that's nice
be wise i appreciate you being here and
i appreciate the interaction that's
happening but
maybe that's what that email is you're
on the internet you got to be careful
with that
don't give out your phone number if you
if you give out your phone number we
gonna start deleting [ __ ]
[ __ ] i just like like a quick speed read
of all these comments with kiki gardener
in the channel oh that's not good
uh good luck and mimi thank you mimi
last black man in san francisco
spotting i was one of the first movies i
brought up in the chat
a huey p newton story by spike lee are
also underrated
the blind side overrated what are you
talking about
the way those white people she's like a
white
knight a white protector one might even
say that she saved him yeah she's a
white person
she's like a she's a salvationist
savored him
she savored him with i don't know what
the word is i'm looking for here
but she has a big saving bullet her
savings
helped this help wise guys great stuff
yeah all right my big takeaway
my big my big takeaway
from the blind side it's not that black
person story
it's how great of a person sandra
bullock's character
i mean yeah kind of i remember that
movie took the world by stormwind
yeah i did and uh it's not as
as as as amazing as its reputation but i
i still enjoyed it and i appreciate
everyone timing about that thing i said
with erica but like
nah that like i have to i have to own up
all right i feel bad and
that that's just that and like [ __ ] that
[ __ ] like
no that was my fault yeah [ __ ] you grace
yeah that's how i mean she said it in
the chat but it wasn't [ __ ] showing
because oh
uh but no i feel awful about oh no um
all right is that
did we do we make it to the to the end
here almost i mean princesses
you guys are [ __ ] thank you so much
for all this crazy support we're getting
right now
so anisa says i had edibles for the
first time in february we did that
okay okay uh eric horseman we read that
jaw eric horseman again i mean anna uh
anissa yes john have you ever been high
before
um lol just wondering
only high on like yeah i've been high
before uh yeah
in what context it's a good time has
john ever been high before
have i ever been high before like height
wise john is i'm tall
always hot i'm only high on this channel
i'm okay i'm tripping mushrooms every
video if john's parents are watching i
need to tell them this right now
they know third grade when john and i
became best friends first thing i did
i got him high that's right and i've
been yeah
influencing me towards the darkness this
guy's
always hot i know what's
i got no motivation i feel
good yo we need to tell you i just need
to tell your parents
you've been high since you were in high
for years ten years old
high for i've even been like
dude you need to chill out on the weed
yeah that's right don't worry i'll stop
someday i can stop whatever i want to
anissa okay okay okay this is my last
one lol love you guys
thank you frank good night to you in
texas it's at least an hour later
princess unicorn nipples what's up
princess unicorn nipples
oh man that's that's that's that's a man
in your photograph this guy
has a masculine figure great nipples so
uh yeah i love your nipples no matter
who you are nipples any day buddy
and msr24 underrated transformers 2007.
i would actually agree with that to a
cerniks thank you by the way my favorite
of the
transformers titled film i would agree
with that because the transformers
franchise is so
panned right it's just so but it's
bookend
by a a pretty damn good transformers
movie
and a [ __ ] great bumblebee movie it's
right there you know
but all the other ones in between have
just made everyone forget this no
there's actually like two really good
ones
you know uh so yeah i'd agree with that
all right
we got one last one here from anissa
rice
uh nisa says john when you said what's
up y'all
lol you sounded like james franco from
spring break
you know what big fan of that movie i
did like that movie a lot and i have a
friend who's a photographer
and my hair is long enough again i
should see if she still wants to she
wanted to do a spring breakers alien
themed photo shoot
with me as alien and i would love to do
that still
i would love to you know make people mad
and get cornrows
yeah i'll take them out right away and
eric horseman
i mean you don't need a super chat for
me appreciate that though
love and peace for sure uh i mean yeah
thank you eric
that means a lot but uh no i i just need
to i mean
i just need to give her space all right
i don't want him i don't want to keep
bringing this up all right
but thank you eric i appreciate that
yeah and thank you for everybody for
your generosity
for your for everyone here
you just click the little eyeball and
then
uh let's see here spring bruh
[Music]
i just sucked y'all's gun dick i got
scarface on repeat
when he's showing them his house yeah
all right so
let's see kiki gardner be safe please be
safe yep yep um
tags a lot of late game love for tag
uh solar eclipse enjoy that
wherever it's visible and uh okay we got
a lot uh y'all
i can see john literally tripping on
mushrooms alex is saying in the chat
daniel jones is underrated daniel jones
your life
is is very underrated there's so much
love in this chat for the movie tag
i know midnight meat train
is underrated i like that movie you know
what early bradley cooper you know what
comedy i would say is underrated game
night
more people should have you seen that
yet i haven't game night
no [ __ ] incredible comedy ooh oh yeah
selena gomez to my aliens
that means you're gonna leave halfway
through the movie and not return to the
movie at all
all right guys well we gotta bounce
but i appreciate eight p.m i appreciate
everyone who's been here
we tried we wanted to make this two
hours went on for three it's the way it
goes that's how we do
um but thank you everyone who
contributed in the super chat over here
at stream labs thank you for all the
love we got
i i love how we kept on topic primarily
for three straight hours yeah man that's
rare for
a lot of under and overrated movies
normally it's the two hour mark we were
able to keep that at
but three hours straight of mainly the
same thing it's pretty incredible for us
so thank you guys
um yeah i don't know how to end this you
guys have been incredible
sorry if i fetched anyone yeah and uh
uh i i'm very much grateful for having
another successful live stream today you
guys be
safe out there be wise keep and let us
know what movies you end up watching
this weekend keep a lookout for next
week's live stream yo
john and he's signing off words guys
thank you for the love
thank you for bringing your thoughts and
opinions and we will see you next week
stay classy stay
safe and hey take part in the world
because now is the time
it's always the time but now more than
ever so much love
take care much love to everyone here